[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo what's going on Louis what's going on
squirrely dan after this call with 7x by
ICU d let me let me let me know if y'all
can in hear us well before you know we
go live and all this you're doing this
stream and stuff you know King thing to
say some to the people you're you was
sub special yeah can hear about the haps
in a date I told you I was going in and
today I hope you'll be an ex is ready
bayonets off-screen just don't paying
that self make sure you heard kick it
all cold with sub thank you brother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh all right ed we are live welcome
actually hopefully welcome mixer and
twitch users we haven't haven't seen you
guys you to the realm joining you guys
pretty new but uh welcome to dialogue
podcast and the Lords of gaming dotnet
episode number 156 there's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm very
excited about our special guest and
we've got Xbox series X Games reveal
game past ten million subscribers The
Last of Us - leaks are summer game fest
and the latest stadia connect to discuss
so we gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who is not only one
of the most charismatic entertaining
Lords in the realm well whose passion
for gaming while incorporating real-life
issues truly makes him one of the
pillars within our gaming community
introducing the created host of the
double xp podcast and the fame
entertainment youtube mixer and twitch
channels the Lord of anime video games
is shenanigans and one of the founding
fathers of Cowboys nation yeah buddy
laughs from Texas and making his
long-awaited debut into the realm of the
Lord's mom made Lord famed
entertainment 2k how you doing sir I
appreciate y'all have me on like it's
been a long time coming man
definitely you know you guys know I know
pulling this you guys are pulling no
Sundays ma'am I know Sunday's were late
now like you guys were going y'all thing
man much better much much love respect
for you guys man and I I got I got a
couple of things I'm building in the
background and yeah you got as somebody
your team has been really helpful and we
building this particular thing so much
love for you guys man i'ma they know
long overdue you are loading in round
one of the old G's we're happy to have
you in the building what you've been
playing fee what's with gaming you've
been doing man
I am the very first console level home
that was just mine with Sega Genesis mmm
family was the street sorry for-4 was
huge for me so I played the mash out of
that game as a way to win it the day
after came out to that Wednesday I've
been playing it non-stop
you know luckily and I just finished a
review for obey me without release or so
which way knows to man that baby keeping
me busy no doubt no doubt that's what
sub chat is already in early shout out
to somebody Smith - super check bayonets
held high chanting the book of X the
bang yo yo you gotta hit us up at OCAD
daddy man a little too cat daddy daddy
got fat stacks with the final check
gears is better than Halo and Gears
tactics is the best gears book it know
now let me close the chapter I don't
know what you're gonna have to sit down
there cat daddy
alright I'm willing to met the gears
tactics is better than all the other
gears thing we're not attacking no so
it's but it's been that going on and all
that good stuff you already know so we
got the four horsemen of gaming the
original laws are um here in the round
table
my co-host ik almost my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of reviews and the heart
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict I died sir doing pretty good
it's been a crazy week and gaming man
yeah you know what's funny as we go from
nothing happening to like everything's
happening everyday boom it's not looking
good for Sony now I've played this gear
tactics I see you brothers I got I got
about almost probably 30 hours in it
like what's devise what survives it's
good like it really is that all
you sleep the Douro issues wilted us
hues issues like I'm not really filling
the side mission stuff at all yes
because you in order to do a main
mission you have to do certain amount of
side missions they make you do the side
missions or the main mission type of
dude three side missions really not
missing you like the hell with this
obvious add new such people are already
talking about my beard shoutout to Z
black rider Saleh I think is Canadian
cat daddy got that last of us to fever
halo forever it's meaty Smurf he's your
salute to addicts beard
I must salute that's right that camera
does that thing thing right there my guy
so that's been a just below you already
face for camera
yeah I beat that last week oh damn
difficult gay khakhra in the building
and of course returning we have almost
1000 members all becoming I got a stop
set out to score lead an 82 with the
file super Chat Noir added getting his
be a game up to try out for the next god
or woman as if I came across Kratos he
would be walking all right
that tells me choose for you actually Oh
tells reaching for be all for me oh wow
alright yo I'll toss we cheat 50 lots of
a check I want card to read this why is
the either shinobi when the man has no
honor it should be the Ronin the samurai
without master the corrupted would
finally catch you alive no overtime this
week I'll watch what is deadly
salut ties we can even be for the
Twitter we got a $20 super chair from
optimus code I can't say I can't stay
but wanted to stop by and show some
support no need to read this support
only beat we still go read it Coco more
fan you family you already know then we
got salzburg right you got cyrus broke
the file a super chat I haven't played
there's tactics though how can we
compare turn-based game to third-person
shooters also at getting a spell out of
it go and of course we have returning of
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single-player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Damas mister offline profile Illuminati
and lower-paid shot of the iron baked
returning my man Louis sovereign how you
doing sir I'm feeling much better
I just you know I I can't have to come
to the realization I'm getting old and
I'm starting to get things that I didn't
even know I was ever gonna I got some
serious allergies going on that I've
never had before so now I have to just
you know a couple months out of the year
is not gonna be fun for me moving
forward we're not gonna cheese baby
gonna cheese cut back on her cheek super
buff up in it oh let me get let me get
this video because he defended my honor
for the file a suit chat there shall not
be any slander guess by do [ __ ] in the
congregation know you heard that time
sweet cheese almost live
shout it to the Lord's for the best
podcast on the Lord's Day I appreciate
you man man oh you guys I'm very
grateful already man we got a great
community absolutely we got 172 let's
get those like slow
saying about likes button view has been
nice but the likes below anyway after
begging to know Russian know it a double
knot thank you to everybody who said
what's up and looked out for me when I
was gone
um yeah so what I've been playing look
like frameset man listen bro listen we
need to have a topic attend to this on
its own
let's go this just taking it to the
streets I I definitely play some more AC
Odyssey and some story revelations and
that blew me away over there oh wow
so I played more of that but once that
Streets of Rage came out I set out to
lizard Q shout-out to duck mu don't
forget girl crush and god crush of
course so in my view they are the
stewards of this franchise moving
forward that's it they they did they
gave you everything that you want in a
side-scrolling beat-em-up
and they did they probably did in a way
what what what coalition did with gears
for right they gave you they gave you
the game that they needed to give you to
show you they they can do it mm-hmm
right and I just want to see to me what
they move forward with cuz I really
don't have much in the way of complaints
about this game at all except for like
that I think the beat them up can evolve
to be even more like long yeah like a
fighting game with more moon encounters
and stuff like that right to me they
gave us the groundwork for what the beat
him up is moving forward for me nobody
touches his franchise but them I mean in
my opinion in my opinion oh my god
fantastic Chad he's like cog he said
tell me playing the new girl with the
old soundtrack it doesn't make you tear
up bro well you throw the retroland too
yeah and the thing is and who've been
playing what ever been playing on game
pass right we we kind of got a little
bit shafted because it was something
that happened that they didn't get the
final patch out in time
so there's stuff in the other versions
like the retro mode they don't aren't
secret modes and stuff like that really
yeah this brush that we're missing out
but that that's for those people that go
to buy so if you wanna know something
loss office pretty speaking to gospel
but is this alright and I understand
they take talking about all the patches
a little bit late I know what it is if
you're gonna pay $60 or whatever the
beginning cost goes out with no because
I got on get past but if you don't pay
whatever the price is of admission you
should get something for your ticket so
they gave you a little warm and fuzzy
playing pixelated mole god bless a less
do you think this void has definitely
been playing his joint on a freebie cuz
I was at Biola by you know you know I
was gonna do the switch verses then I
was like you know what I'm home I'm
playing the game fast version and I'm
gonna tell you this man like like like
frames said like this is the type of
game you finish with one character you
jump on or within it with the next one
because it's a it's a totally different
feeling experience with each character
and then when you bring in the fact that
whoa once we get all these patches or
whatnot in here you could play with
every version of the character then each
dreaming so each version of that
character is different like you know
blaze fielding from future age two is
very different from Vegas
one in three so it's like it's almost
like you're playing a brand new game go
lay the face forward and backwards yeah
over moves cover forward and backwards
so yeah it's not one of those things
were you ever really caught being jumped
from both sides
yeah no you right about that sherry goes
hard anything I like about her what I
mind is the distinction wet the smaller
characters got a - she got a - so she
comes yeah around again he'll tell you
when see cuz you know when I start I
start with Axl yeah yeah mixing it with
Axl so I got my butt smoked shut up you
go playing by yourself it's not good for
your health man get my mud smoke and I
said you know shorty girls that work in
that guitar crack in a forest off yo
little Alicia Keys is busy I wish there
was foreplay really I want us all to
really play the roles they ask they like
it's foreplay we actually tweeted them
as our Yoda Tamil this is what the fans
want is if you could not we spoke to the
backpacks and we did talk about the four
player but we like young we need to get
this on line now the hit again I'm not
saying this is exclusively definitely
gonna happen but we were told at the
time then yeah it could happen you with
next-generation cosmic open we get that
past for playing online it's the perfect
beat them with issues or play a local
right for play - no we was going that
check out the video the video is up he's
doing that up in fact C's for player you
know get busy your tie in the back with
the it was crazy you know what I think I
think it's long for a beat em up like it
was 12 stages and towards the end some
of the stages are very short on the
stages have multiple areas and towards
the end there's like two or three stages
it's like it's like four or five screens
in the state to go if it is over
yeah super size real quick somebody
Smith he said I can't even front sherry
is fire attic you want to get that other
one on the Smitty so we got a $2.00
super chair from some idiot I can't even
front cherry is fired when I sue that
character off that game I'm not slate
that you talking about another $2 $2
super traffic from Smitty Smitty
when cherry jump on your chest it's over
the rest is the red node us it has been
a yeah it's pretty much it man I get my
retro on you already know and of course
we have the Incredible Hulk of this
a.k.a the XS gamer ooh the lord of
combat sports king of the statues who
demands nothing less than a premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement Oh beloved Lord King how
we doing sir
before we get to started you know what
it is it that Hulk right there's for the
people they don't want to spend that
premium dollar don't want to get in and
you know let your bucks count man I
think it's a buck 65 shipping and
handling all that in it that's it little
statue to have in your collection as you
can see on the side I got a bunch of
them dudes over there
and a ton more inside the other room so
you know that stuff definitely gets you
in a lot of people wants to know I get
hitting the dams all the time I go to
sideshow calm also go to XM calm I'm not
sponsored by these people but they
definitely y'all put in their work I'm
gonna tell you right now once you start
be careful as tags they collected big
chat rage injustice is just as good
would it be nice to see 3d versions and
guilty gear like graphics of agree I
don't know about justice is good but we
ain't gonna go for the gold piece of
rage is better than I'll be honest when
it came out and kick final fight in the
UK okay so this is what I've been
playing was getting
shout out to that game pass Dominus
Maximus Spencer it's going to be a
really really soon because when you go
and you put a game that has been highly
anticipated a game that pulls at any and
any og game
strings on God and NIMH when that joint
hit game past it was it yo if no dream
hit game pass in this game pick game
past is justified any type of purchase
that you did for a sega head mmm I
remember going to get the cartridge I
think we all split up that day mm-hmm we
all went purchase we all looked each
other in the eyes and said this is where
we popped hey we came back later like
Voltron yes this was say go say goes on
a roll like you gotta understand Sega
this was win underdog just looked over
and just said eff it I'm going all in
all in and this is when the Sonic was
hitting misses when streets of rages
they put an answer to anything Nintendo
said and this was the answer for 5/4
final fight was our serious joint enough
for them to not final fight the beat
alone no you my man gotta go to the bush
that's tough and you are not beating
streets I don't care who you are you are
not beating Streets of Rage you throw
your favorite beat him up against him
and Streets of Rage is gonna beat them
back what about especially this part for
this Lauren gave you every retro feel
and every retro sound and every retro
look and then gave you the modern
contemporary joint now the cartoon
animation they're like a comic book my
guy you mean dylon boy's head but now I
don't like I don't like the
disrespectful or Iron Fist looking dudes
with the hands in the press with the
yellow to green they be trying to sell
you
young folk okay so you know I was
already over the moon to that but
speaking to over the moon deliver us the
moon oh yeah I got a shout out the gene
you want some shred up shop with the
great review up warlords it gave me that
kind I knit the shouts at carnac went by
messing me up yeah yeah I joined his
fireman I heard a lot of good things
about it you put you gotta go down with
it yeah boy that it's it's it's like a
good mail you know you're gonna take the
time with it you're gonna check
everything out and and also i got to the
point where i was taking pictures of
stuff on the screen because i knew i was
going to need that information when
crunch time hit right and thank God I
did because when crunch time hit I had
to pull up that screen to make sure what
levers and stuff I had to push at a
certain time and if you didn't even
memorize it in the beginning yes boy
make sure you get that screen check but
also was playing dr. Roboto right
and um wrong dog the long dog finally
made it out of the preview program right
I made it into game pass a date and date
type of situation my brother's actually
obsessed with that game all the time
[Music]
I'll be I'll be walking in there I'm
like what do you do nice like running
from there yeah it's a hell of a
survival game and it puts you in the
mindset of being in this frozen land and
it's it's just a such a good game I just
got to give it up to a field ominous
maximus spencer soon to be Aurelius that
game Pass has a level of diversity that
is unmatched
all right in the reason why I say it's
unmatched because you can see yellow
PlayStation now I'm which is PlayStation
later I haven't jumped into PlayStation
later because it don't make the noises
is is it's a raging in exactly that's
what I'm
talking about like how can you pull up
talking about you got a premium service
and your service ain't really premium
dude you ain't got no shrimps
you ain't got no shrimps inside your
buffet my man I'm going to the back
beating up the shrimp's in two day old
hot dog that's what I've been doing I
can't wait to that full player patch it
up so you can do a live session with
everybody all in this that's the perfect
game for the Lord's the stream no idea
let me get oh yeah promise brat with the
Tassimo chess salute Lord Streets of
Rage for that music and then he say
Harris Oh viola super chat next gen 2k
basketball and Madden will be beautiful
and there's no if you want to get all
James 176 James 176 hold on once that
stage everybody's going over oh no we
got Forte we know James 176 to the phyto
super chat Lord cog do you and the rest
of the iron Lords have a huge amount of
respect to the devs of Streets of Rage
for after playing and interviewing them
at PAX thank you brother much appreciate
ours that was like the highlight for us
like as the og Sega kids dream come true
game it's a loop thank you for watching
yeah we've been interviewing them for
when we first saw the game the year
before yeah from the transformation from
the Yip it blew us away we walked away
with it knowing what was coming yeah and
then they still hit us with a surprise
yeah her with the retro in the yeah man
they really did I want a shout-out on
was it but Sarila Gary and then the
director than as far as Benfica he
doesn't get enough credit cuz he's the
actual artist and to me that's what
makes his shine it looks so it's
straight out of a comic book page man it
shot that I'm doing man they really kill
it but that's been they are king as far
as what you've been yeah yeah listen I
can you know I was playing destiny you
know
they're working and I finally had to
take my um my second character because
you cannot finish the Guardian games
without taking out all three of your
characters they put the grind on your
neck and I had to bend the knee my knees
are on the ground pause and I just had
to just give it up cuz it's over so we
got a couple of yeah we got a few more
set up the angry therapist MD the file
to attach Street service are you okay
finish the soup yeah I'll finish them
off rage for was a love letter to the og
fans and I love it and I could not agree
more about to gaming for table to two
dollar super chat fame plucked Lords on
a Sunday what is better my brother
salute and we have stitch 66 69 he with
the $5 every week so in support and
today I must say cognos which topic
let's go doing good unlike Sony bag this
week kiante Harris with the $5 took
attack never would have played Metro
expedite the hell blade if it wasn't the
game past definite game change no but my
question was who's winning that Guardian
games right now all my question is it
that is it that dirty Conan
the bushes for free also Titans are what
they want every week except the first
it's it was funny they come out and say
that it wasn't rigged just to show it's
bad it's bad
it's fix is fixed I hate I hate destiny
for gota
he's our Smitty Smith but when I when I
roll I roll with the time spreading that
realness in the Roma tell you what you
need to hear yeah man you guys said it
best Streets of Rage for all day man I'm
a Porsche power from the season gaming
network that has been my coop buddy
we've been rockin we did the femme
fatale one day he was blaze I was cherry
you know I'm saying then of a day I did
I got unlocked Adam so I was getting the
old-school Adam or he took it to the
old-school axe so he's getting busy so
he's messing around with the coop
specifically online um no shout-out to
to get on to the pc version on the PC
game past version Hoshi's rage fam I
cannot launch this game it's a known
issue apparently
oh yeah it's about to load and then
nothing to happen no shout out shout out
there's no issues of PC gaming though
yeah yeah
but I got to play it fine there's a lot
of people that's having the same issue
but you know just take yourself over to
console cuz the first time I tried to
load it up and did give me an issue but
it wasn't the game itself when I checked
the hard drive that I had it on wasn't
appearing the entire hard drive
once I started the computer hard drive
came back and the game was fine
restarted the computer everything see
all my other games launched I got gears
tactics on there on the gamepad some no
problem streets erase what it does it
it'll give it a splash screen that if I
went to load you'll see the loading but
then nothing happens
[Laughter]
yeah I'll get restored here my bad my
wall I've gotta step it up hashtag it's
fixed set out the restored Hades with
the final super chaste Streets of Rage
for is amazing and it feels so retro I
just wanted to ask the panel does
playing Streets of Rage get you excited
for Battletoads actually yes yes yes yes
I will tell you right now Battletoads
was just battle told the original was
not a great game per se
it didn't feel everything trash it was
difficult oh yeah what I know King
played it at e3 and what they've done
the key component to any beat'em up is
the feel yeah you have to be you it's
got to feel good like when you punch
somebody that feeling um from what I get
that's what they're doing did you
battletoads like you know okay like
castle crashes and stuff like that like
all of those games we've sort of the
build up to what we see in Streets of
Rage for and what we're hopefully gonna
be saying in battle too so if you're a
beat-em-up fan like these games coming
forward like they really kind of up the
up the ante and come to your battle toad
a real-life cartoon yeah yeah I set out
to see black rider with the file a suit
yet damn I want to oil addicts beard oil
this the PC version is due to race for
like mark Cerny not showing games yes
that me it is shout out to Brock with
the flower super chat [ __ ] you to reach
for longer got my piece I can almost
guarantee you that cardi knows PC is way
better than your not actually know Brad
gotta get the bad rap
oh it's crazy but I had three people who
tested the same issue shout - sinister
shout to how much people if you look
over there there discord therefore
there's a problem it's a known issue
it's a no-name so I don't know maybe the
steam guys you got
so fine but I wasn't paying for that
because you don't go there for a while
for peas there for a while the know when
mutiny zero went into game pass yes it
wasn't low and wouldn't launch on PC on
the on the game pass version either like
some there's issues with that game pass
that's why it's in a beta and it's like
they gotta fix that yeah well you know
me knowing that these things is going on
that's Anna we know from limited-run I'm
waiting I'm waiting on my Noah Phil told
me when you got a double dip save your
money game yeah we got another superstar
from LMNOP la da super qiat-ps bus gotta
bend the knee to not having Streets of
Rage 4 instead of giving us farming
simulator you don't like grapes
we ship in October oh it's gonna be a
few months from now so we never get it
fall away well that's that's when it's
gonna come inside our PlayStation now
four months from now oh those are good
games like I don't mind those type of
games they put on so like I guess I
didn't care but I was like yo play say
she killing these games again and just
like they usually always do then I go on
Twitter and let go everyone else doesn't
think so
you mean her PS fluff stop the farming I
mean that's fine you know it was that a
lot of people remember the Xbox's came
out first and people were ripping them
because they seemed like they were not
great games and so remember there was a
rumor that a fiesta PS month was like
dying light and something else I forgot
there was worry it was not that
obviously guess tactics I got it was
saying I was messing around there really
enjoying that production values off the
chain
like I really enjoyed a whole when you
kill someone you get to go again it's
all it's a very difficult game because
it's [ __ ]
of them but it's very deep with the
skill trees and everything yo they got a
billion play they might be on to
something you know I'm really feeling it
man I gotta I gotta say everybody that
didn't want that game nobody now top
running these stupid mouth
remember when good like I want them to
buy Splash Damage like that cuz you know
I always joke around you know they need
to get splash damage because Splash
Damage makes these type of games Owen
mm-hmm but it's so good that I'm like
they really need a pice place but isn't
that a knee-jerk reaction that we have
to anytime a studio does something this
is how you know you're beat into
submission
any time a studio does something good
from for Microsoft for from Microsoft
that is not a part of Microsoft we want
them to instantly hire them because we
feel that they need these level of games
to have this high medical floor because
it's this foam oh you're really looking
over at Sony we got a tip the hat to
know down definitely got a tip to hat
because when they come to those Triple A
bangers we understand that they
definitely put in that then we already
know anytime Nintendo brings out any
type of game you're like you know
anything really did well with detection
was though real quick check card I
downloaded it from K pass love and
expiry big shout out to Fame great to
you great to see it will the Lords be
interested in a Double Dragon we make I
mean you know me and Double Dragon neon
was not the mold Barbie no that was not
it man so that's all pretty much I got
man we've been rocking and of course
you're doing a little
trials are on stadion oil actors South
to Fort Asia I'll scroll laughs Oh
Smitty Smith we got to keep it more but
we gonna get you they beefed it you want
to get it got a ten dollar super chair
from Smitty Smith Chris Hart
let me get this straight saving money is
a bad thing
game passes fantastic man you better
save money for that overeating SSD
looking at crystal heart start a beef
early we got a lot of shows we gonna get
into it but now that we got into what
the Lord's have been playing I want to
start with Lord fame his video game
system history his journey as a writer
and content creator and what led him to
leveling up creating the 2xp podcast
soul or fame I heard that Genesis I
heard other things but let's start from
the beginning video gaming for me you
know I had to like the game is yours so
you you go make 64 and I had another
game called Vivi calm race oh yes that
was that was my joint run you can tell
me nothing about beating Congress and
they have an amazing sense no I wouldn't
mana break it down break it down real
quick fade like what was the dedicated
me or to diddy kong's I always missed
out on that one amazing it's the best
part for that ever was there we had a
good car
I had a decent look this little story
mm-hmm the characters were were were
different and it says it was just fun to
play man and a hard to scribe but it
wasn't like other races at the time yeah
you had balls races yeah the ball
Francis was told it was super hard and
frustrating and the key if I'm trying to
play their game so diddy kong racing was
what was it for me man I was 64 you
couldn't tell me nothing I bet my box it
oh you have to did it like it like a car
oh oh shout jdub mm check with the
eyeballs shout to fame to K you know
about IOP brothers you know Texas in the
house I love the fact that you hear
j-dub cuz you bout to get this work oh I
know what you know my honest opinion is
on that whole Diddy Kong Racing thing is
Fame I think that Nintendo sacrificed
that so Mario car could flourish man
that's a good point
because they never did it again no and
it was a little it was legit you had
different characters who they're turning
with different speed was just like every
every character you to come racing play
different know em I kind of felt the
same the same who like the power to how
you use it but when this song the racers
raised differently like - I like your
style of racing yes that's why we like
the matter and Martin do that I only put
them must never backing date and that's
what made it different - Mario Kart but
they play different that's what's up
know that that's what's up
so that you went from yeah I could say
Genesis did you had then what did you
transition to from then man then I was
almost straight hood clicking all the
straight pony man appeared what Pierce
what was that fire
[ __ ] that's I believe them
uranium planters join yours mine talk
about that ps1 fan let's talk about it
man that thing my favorite game was
there was a resident evil 3 was a
nemesis that was my joy I played the
game non-stop on a ps1 man you could
tell me nothing about the game class
Vienna mm-hmm and I'm going to the ps2
okay man and then then the Xbox it came
out I was like no fame fame at the end
of the day was it better than the n64
controller n64 controller was tied to go
though if that rumble in the controllers
the first to do Rumble wait it was the
first to do you guys have lost your mom
in 64 controller was hole perfect for
their games with you I didn't like the
original Xbox controller either
controller was the better one attic is
coming from being this is gamecube
that's when you started don't make this
about my age I have to make it about
your age because you got to remember we
was playing with these little
controllers these new NES controllers
they're like yes facts right so when we
got it head alone stick remember say
them tried that analog joint well
something was a digital with a little
stick inside and always broke off yeah
so you had it for like a couple of days
with the Master System and then
broke off and everybody had that little
thing that was cutting your finger in
the master system and you had to file it
down so your things will get messed up
and so when they came out with the
analog and it it was durable it stood up
and you can creep with Mary it game
change the game it changed it it's like
they brought something completely
different then when you put the rumble
packet and the first time we fell in
number I'm not referring to the n64
controller bad isn't back then because
that's all we knew right I'm referring
to it as now as a control yeah but you
know what was super dope I like I think
black people underrated cuz I had a I
had a Game Boy Color too when I was
going big on your pokemon yellow I just
have to point out we had to guess I
could relate from you know like that oh
gee tall a good to you Fame and up a
Genesis a dream can okay and that was my
joint to and I'm awkward think about
that of course was that memory card that
was you know things going off yeah that
was super dope man no I didn't get a GE
bet Spock until right before the ps3
drop because I just really wasn't I mean
I played it a lot cousin you'll make my
cousins come over my ball with us I
played all the games you know I didn't
miss I know game I just did oh you just
ought to know oh yeah did you all watch
mm-hmm I don't want to write before ps3
nothing the very first console I
actually owned like owned owned was the
n64 what made you go buy it could you do
the $600 feels like you now will be
buying an Xbox
No happy what-what would make one maybe
go get it was a super dope alright I
really got into music and I love being
able to put my CD in and listen listen
to news no matter what I was playing
with the loser
yo failed I gotta stop cuz you got the
bomb right now you want something right
let me tell you dad joy is so underrated
when they will let you burn your CD
tracks ins when they use it as a
soundtrack for it for your games are
like people honestly in a hard drive and
the Xbox one changed a game you couldn't
do that private continued that was
because that was so well received they
ended up doing the play it over
everything
[Laughter]
[Applause]
talk to me about that that Xbox day so
what made you do it
yeah okay I'm out there joint and then
it was like yo eidart experience you
know greatest halo from those when tears
came out I was like
let's this is getting there right here
like that was to me that was a a pillar
answer I we the next gene again now it's
nice that you bring that up Fame because
like I hear a lot of people you know
always talk about certain things when it
comes to you know consistency and track
record and I'm like we literally went
from the 360 that that spawned gears
that spawned like hey Lord its height
yes there was no more consistency than
that to them dudes man yeah yeah
continue continue
definitely and so you know from that
point man I just and that BS people cut
it it kind of just set that like I
didn't really play it as much cuz I
dared ahead now I was I was on the Xbox
Live I was and then around that time I
like you to notice I see you complain
that met oh and so I just I used to be
all over the place out if the
city-states playin man and uh I would
what you consider a casual gamer for
about three four years all I did was
play mad if you can or you go to my
profile and look back on three six
you'll see all of Madden's and you seem
just our but hey bro I'm with you I come
from that like I'll be obviously you
took it to the next level doing really
competitive and travel yeah really being
out there but we can't afford I mean
shot the King saw being mad at me but it
was me you know say if it's not we had a
whole crew that with a manager hey we
would do tournaments and like that was
the thing man the franchise molds and I
was upset that they took our baby Paul I
don't care what you were doing
I find the cheese plate and I'm going to
keep running it down your balls and I
don't know we gonna be tired I'm gonna
make sure in the fourth quarter
we are tired up and when I'm gonna get
the ball anyway yeah any over and I put
the controller down and I yell out baby
it was so cheesy he was due to play to
win to get I did put the controller down
and
be tight sir because you can't remember
remember um what was the sports talk oh
whoa the halfback pass yo I was so happy
to hear when they came out I could talk
some bad a little bit faith man they
finally came out with defensive
assignments and I was like hey I'm gonna
put my man my best corner Charles what's
he gonna be on your man the only real
experience I have with us it was on the
Sega the only road experience which one
was the one that had the screen on the
controller oh okay I remember my cousin
Marty what I was played with them
because he'd always talked so much like
I beat you have met I never played this
game don't even really know balling he's
like but I'm only gonna play if you beat
the AI one time they were beating me man
they will make me hate life so you know
what I literally started you know
thought you could switch back and forth
between teams yeah yeah I would
literally switch to the other team make
them like go make make them tumble or do
something and they go back with max I'm
about the beaters dude when he when I
finally play man he smoked me man he'll
be able to do that yeah I gotta get
these super tears real quick I think we
got Smitty Smith or may still be for
Chris DeVos Chris you can't a great me
brother
I'm from the house of looks Osiris at a
Korra the book of X then we got only
that sexist in the building fast back oh
gee nlg pocket your see my pack south
friend at the round table so he salute
to see you know it's all we got from BG
the first four months gaming months of
20/20 has been it adds like yeah say
what they want you know I get it you
know I I like doing the addict world and
and and this year
attic world's nice I'm the mayor you
know your games you good yeah this yeah
this is the best send-off I think
generation nowhere close to being done
that's the funny part
Yonsei Harris mm hm at an almost
unplayable now yeah I got an actual yes
you want to get offstage I doubt that
stays and shaves the $18 super chat
little late to the party we got to show
some love mark this down I think we'd
have some breaking news 149 p.m. May 3rd
2020
Microsoft has acquired two major devs
they will have all jaws on the floor
today
now Kevin who's talking like
I'm over here like ten-year-olds get it
- it was a life lesson
no matter the effective Francis Miele
video piyo shelter on set
remember when man and ran at 60 frames
per second only on 360 Wow yeah shoutout
to 30 like this generation oh my god
behave jeez Louise get out of some jet
flute man leaked the last of us to
people people say one of those two
studios are tickling okay unless I'm
light be serious Oh James a follow-up
did did I miss any new Jerome details
when I get to the halo that was the
transition going over there and he was
rocking with the 360 it is three sinks
you are the man by the time even though
you know sorta gin it's more criticals
kind of kind of Thank You me addict was
talking about this yeah they have to
gain from the gin of these kind of I
think they kind of relied on too much of
a formula from the priestess or in the
360 they didn't really belong with
exclusive two months that they get 720
deals they had Gamache ain't no
PlayStation is a worldwide right Xbox
justinian on face alone what's keeping
up with the sounds of PS fat right and
so I think they rely too much on the 360
degrees start the Xbox one yeah we got
third-party doctors we got that but the
game they had rival super underrated
they get us have some super dope games
around before yo this is a constant
I think ups for maybe a year or two or
to the gym right now why was the game
that made you say you know I gotta get
this pants photo oh man I really want I
really want to dig dig until I finish on
charger serious like oh hey player I've
ever been on one I want to finish this
is my yo I gotta grab this joint
people come to me I'm an actor I have to
get that you see four men here from
there I say the whole bar thing that's
all talking around me at the day you
know it's all gaming so my name is which
you know my game on that top man I'm all
over the place now yeah yeah but look
you continue over phase history shout to
game about choice to our chat remember
the man and then let you create the
plays yes I do remember that man yeah we
got two more we got dr. kids move the to
us with chat facts dudes on Facebook -
war fresh curly Dan with the super chat
installed an understood vote me it was
just like destiny oh yeah of course I'm
like okay let me Charlie shout out the
Hannibal for bamboozling me that soon as
you put that game and you
literally run around one time like now
I'm doing just now for me so tremendous
game info fave out here killing it you
already know well of course you already
know we're skin into your journey as a
content creator bags obviously we were
all together at one point of the tail
say and then before they leave it at
history like said double xp podcast
writer's block but kiss movies at the
man down almost good days ransom I got
the Xbox when I really got into the
social I would even know social media so
I got social media and I met up with a
yellow anchorman be off cause he was my
first introduction into into YouTube
I've been you know on that's on this
side off a super dope and I lift up with
the guys from Wii game here salute and I
was rocking with them for a while and
their me and Rafe and we came here as
part of the hard-knock game was yeah
that was yes and I what's funny favors
back then it wasn't a get each other on
Twitter says he likes Xbox
what's a face 23 BK file and super a
canoes chases try to just post it to
Twitter hackers got ahold of an early
build of the game and the story is that
the the last of us to thing will get to
it we get to it but we'll see yeah
that's what it is I was reading earlier
that he got like more more concrete
evidence about what actually happened
okay we will get to it we'll talk about
it all the time until you man good old
days talk again
we add that on the witch code the riders
black bow topper yeah the whole history
let's go oh so by the time we go from
from hard night we met up with Cal from
from taking their word and if I yo like
what y'all doing over there anchor kind
of broke with the deal he's doing a hell
of a man and then keep me a kid and a
baby guy we all went over it got over
that's it mm-hmm and that's my time we
want to writer's block it was me undead
Oh
kid kid smooth let's come in a guy like
you might not remember Nicodemus
no she does uh what you got the same big
blue but that was a writer's block and
we had like math I think kids who posted
a video yeah I saw it it was classy I'm
dancing bro we had so much fun
Romelu we had math but of course things
happy you know kinda had a fallout with
the guys that we came you're hard not
you know just doing my thing you know
over that's it
and uh shall I set out to count over
that man cuz I really got my first
experience you know I've been writing
before I got my first experience really
going to conventions you know where
developers are doing interviews like
that so like even though I'm not with
dick anymore right just just recently
added up loses the things I got cooking
with in the background I get it leave
recently by I was able to get into last
place I never done before first I never
would have before so yes and so over the
years I've done my best to craft you
know my writing skills my interviewing
skills really really not been afraid to
go for the pros i I've met you know like
to see you all from different companies
you know when I was in a party at which
party you know they invited us all the
walki and I'm a big twist dream as I see
the CEOs man oh that's why I talking two
years ago I would've done that I'm gonna
use in the background not like oh you
see my name is sue their business cause
well that did interview we're gonna put
up a lot of different stuff man I kind
of been put on there so
my Chinese goal from somebody who did
nothing but play mac hmm
somebody who's sitting here sipping you
know cocktails whoa
and millions [ __ ] Twitter twitch
streaming stuff like that man late me if
you have because I want to salute you
man because again I remember we go over
there and again get shot the cow for
giving people an opportunity we always
got to respect that
you know at the end of the day it's like
I remember I was like yo Fame rights to
like I didn't even know that I seen
y'all out there and I know dizzy
inabilities I got I got a shout out the
Tecton Texas gang you know saying like I
see interviewer you were Dallas man
little double legs feed I was good we
gotta step on out here man it was just
so cool to see it just you guys with the
developers are talking and that's what
we caught inspired to do it
so sleuth you guys the question I had to
ask for you don't so just me keep this
straight Texas I wanted to ask you like
how's the culture the scene down like a
pack Salvador lat how is it cuz I don't
we like the Lords of the North you ask
me go to eat yeah we do all our New York
or Boston or lat like how's the Texas
game and seeing when you go into those
conventions and all that yo honestly
like when you go like like QuakeCon
Great Khan is here in Dallas man once
you walk up you hear name Oh what I fav
and that's my come give your big old hug
oh yo what up this is oh man the Texas
CMAs mad love you know the first time I
was at quake and I met up with three
paths got people matters oh yes Oh him
link to my hey ray are you I'm over here
looks like it so we linked up seeing us
you know we send top and we drinking we
here to the to the after-party
hey not the party we still sitting it
everybody down here man Texas it's just
man who [ __ ] no way con two packs if I
saying people go to these conventions so
everybody know each other so that's like
all love polka too strong that's the
game in Mecca Jesus it's packed with
cowboy hats and bougie I gotta stop I
gotta stop
[Music]
[Music]
real quick for the to us to protect
remember when Madden used to be a game
in the bushes daddy with the two dollars
which I X clouds the only reason I touch
this year's mad old town ropes the Texas
love it here man salute man yo so like I
said bad tremendous tremendous history
tremendous game and seeing your growth
you don't I'm saying and I recently just
got switch gears for a second man
obviously you know recently you've gone
through a lot brother you know I'm
saying and I want to shout you out
because you put something out there on
YouTube that really touched my heart you
made me tear up at the end of the day
are why we clapping for the terrorists
okay okay I'm not the day like you know
we don't as a parent damn it going on
and I really want to salute you for
being personal being honest and also
just give you your rules while you could
smell a man because you know things were
very serious for you so you have a video
up there you know gamers any maa when
you're gonna say the name you're not
YouTube do but whatever I'm saying but
at the end of the day like could you
talk about that experience how it
changed you you know I'm saying with
everything and then like just you know
surviving and all that kind of stuff man
cuz you went to it you definitely may it
changed me a lot
I got to call a big Rhona yes but for
the most part man like before I was
actually admitted to the hospital and
and I think my wife about this I was
laying in well be in our house our
designated isolation room we talked
about hey one of us get it just
isolation roll we're gonna try not to go
to the hospital because we all know the
hospital's a pet and he gotta be dying
for you to go there here and
the day before that is the morning of
before I was meant to the hospital I
laid there man
my heart my heart rate was like 115 I
wasn't moving and I feel like I was
running when Sprint's I'm sitting I
couldn't breathe everyone my temp was
like 100 and 200 3 and I told myself
like this the day I died like this is it
you know I called my wife in I'm giving
her all the passwords to emails how to
pay the mortgage
mmm all of that stuff just to make sure
you know real man stuff when when I do
they take care of you know I got I got a
really decent good life insurance policy
I would make my film it's good there's
my big like yeah I'm definitely God
today men went to went to the hospital
and it was it was just a surreal feeling
because once we once you get to the door
you're my wife she couldn't go past like
that once it was like it wasn't anyone
no kiss goodbye
what no hug goodbye it was just like
it's just you were in the wheelchair
getting pushed a little the bottom floor
just empty all you seeis nurses and my
tip hit like 100 a for must 105 I'm
burning up inside you know I'm I was
like yeah this is gonna be it I'm I'm 32
out of there because I'm never decently
good life but this this is a rep I don't
do blessed blessings of God man and and
and my body decided what my day I was
able to fight to and and I get to it man
they was I'm saying right I'm gonna bid
say ain't no cure for this right now
they they gave me was what they called a
peel cocktail they were just throwing
appeals at me and I was like whatever
Marvin Lane ain't no no better man and
then my wife she was clutch me and she
bagged all my stuff for me man I had my
switch hooked up man she definitely took
care of a man and the day the day I was
able to leave and go home and it was it
was it was unbelievable I looked at my
wife and I was like is this real like
that I died cuz some perspective like
when you die like you're your you won't
see your heaven yeah yeah oh my heaven
was to make my family you know so I was
ever get back to him and I'm not gonna
lie I still have moments where if I
think about my son Wayne y'all no more
non-game brain I wanted to go into that
room we want to run this break our team
room had too many bad memories and uh be
a man like us out I ended up being
positive for Kobe a man and my lungs
were shy they were smile hockey is long
they belong small and it definitely suck
the things fun think about it is when I
recovered I had a new aspect on
everything it's one of the reasons
behind me leaving tip is because I had
some ideas of mine and I was comfortable
hmm I was kind of just sit back and I
was like all right this is all right
cool whatever
comfortable really comfortable and me
pretty much getting a second chance so
life I was like I gotta I gotta make the
move that's in my head to me I'm not
dude I got do these different things
next I hit up I hit a cop I came in I I
can't rely on the status quo right now I
got a second chance on life I can't go
back to just kind of laying back and
seeing how things go and and that kind
of that's prompted me one to do things
I'm doing working on now was because I I
got a second chance to like that a lot
of people think it's a lot brother the
guy in the room next to me that's passed
away me that's the stuff when you told
that story of you being in that room and
when first came in
you looked at his condition and you felt
he was close and then to your journey
and you said some powerful things but
like you know how the virus basically
wants you to die
it does you forced yourself no I'm gonna
get up I'm gonna go to the bathroom I
mean even if it you said a classic lie
anything that makes you uncomfortable do
it you gotta do it because that was part
of the fight and here you do that and
then to go to it then you come through
it but on your way out
you noticed that that see what Garson
was gone yeah it was old it was an older
gentleman and you could hear him one of
the nights that my even my nerves bolted
out of aroma and they left my door
cracked open you can just hear what's
going on round one fight I was like this
man this man who's just like me but
that's the key anybody made you get sick
whatever you'll buy something you not to
do in a nurse tell you oh penis Cup you
know work on
little blowing thing like you like you
saying this right now and I had to sit
through to grandmother's doing that and
that's brother god bless my hotness hey
I appreciate I definitely appreciate
this is there something I don't I don't
I don't wish on nobody except maybe the
people who are spreading the disease
right now by being at the beach and
beyond it's not real it's not real
thinking is a joke until a Jew in life
and I love what you said you know you
wanted to know you kind of reflective
looking at things kind of taking your
destiny in your hand so you'll have to
spoil if you chorist is ridiculously
bright right now I have what without
last full of things because my team
would kill ok don't doubt fair enough
511 2020 okay I'll be looking out on
your timeline you're working on I'm
gonna shot some people with the the the
people who are who are on the team it's
gonna be a fun time like I said you guys
are like like a big inspiration for me I
hit a busier like a me yada-yada
you got you guys a big inspiration to me
man so I'm super grateful to be here I'm
super burger to talk with you guys man
and I can't wait to come out on the 11th
and the meantime you guys I'm listening
man go follow at level one gaming yes I
learn with her day I was filing
incorrect right and I had to update to
your to do dance but I think
because because they used to say to HP
yeah I was like weird since I was
hashtag it's always act like a repeated
so people do the following at work
it's lz1 gaming no number one no doubt
level one game you already know salute
on that man tremendous gaming history
tremendous story powerful pie again if
you have not watched you go to fame
entertainment suitcase YouTube channel
his personal story is a gamers AMA with
about the virus about his struggle about
everything it is powerful highly advise
you to watch it go keep it positive so I
gotta ask the question that I ask all
the Lords in the realm Fame you know I'm
saying I need those top five video games
or franchises of all time let's go okay
oh man let's go in any order any or any
order it could be either one particular
game or the entire franchise itself okay
let's go
halo - let's get it
oh I gotta put my original Streets of
Rage in there Oh first needs a raises
let's go Super Mario Brothers 3 the
original Shenmue listen you won't come
back so you can always revise this
that's what I do fall I guess cuz they
blame okay I said kiss boo said no Zelda
please because I love the sports so much
sport I'm about Mike Tyson's punch-out
I love boxing and that was my
introduction it's a really you know
playing a boxing game like Little Mac
you saw Mike Tyson
you saw the gap in his teeth when he did
the flash flash bro you got his teeth
chipping it was all like you ain't won
no smoke when that teeth that I go to
yeah it was when you finally beat that
him the ball is taking your Oh put that
out there when you finally beat him it
really felt like you accomplished
something in his life we had Nintendo
guru why he was like you know he ran out
to old friends in the street like he
really delve in [ __ ]
last question this is one latest edition
now I'm curious cuz you got it you got a
tremendous console history so I gotta
ask what your favorite console is of all
time and why only pick what any
generation yeah this is tough this is
the tough one because you've been one
other brother my heart wants to say it's
the 360 okay but my brain is telling me
listen to yourself you know what's the
ps2 Oh beat the amount of quality games
that came from that console it's
astronomical break it down break it down
but when you first put a game in and
just seeing that the loading screen it
does some to you yes it does it does I'm
feeling on that ps2 man you know if the
game was scratch you hope it is
something about some like the ps2 man in
the
James man and use Final Fantasy Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy minutes or
something about a miami-dade fax it on
and on CBS to my mind says bed but the
360 called in mark because it made me
and to just more it made me to the game
I entered a it transition me over to
another realm again row you ain't lyin
cuz it listen how much as we all have
our favorites kidding me and you can
attest it is solved you can helps to
this that's the only console I spent a
straight up G to get the Japanese joint
early I wanted that protected what I'm a
tech nut I'm a competitive tech enough
like are you mad and I'm competitive
target so when I saw Tekken Tag
Tournament and the mouse was moving and
the set I was like yeah this is great
like that dry remember that Madden was
revolutionary at its time bad it from
yes to yes or them when we was camping
out in the helmets and I'm like yo this
is different this is your friend this is
this is something else man shout out the
fit y es tuyo that [ __ ] it was a jump
man it was a game day I was mad and I
don't remember but I know when the knee
had to go down it was when I saw the
little mad and shoulders yeah we would
and cuz this is what they did like the
line is all right yes so we didn't know
that we was gonna be there for damn near
two days
so we sitting out there or camped out
friends and it felt really good getting
into our community but then on the
screen they gave us a treat and to what
I anticipation yes
and that Madden shoulder I said this is
the greatest looking thing I've ever
seen in my life
it was crazy but we would we have eyes
back this we did they had two eyes they
all had the same face you know as much
you know joking that you know we kind of
joke around that we do on the
PlayStation like without that platform
as a whole like expressly ps1 I you know
gaming might not ever have evolved it
was it was Tom Brady on the cover Tom
Brady oh here we go here we go we got a
bunch man no no actually you got but you
got fast back before that okay get it
get it get the fast back hold on cat
daddy no cat daddy before him I think
you know I did the mat and when I got
that one okay cool cool yeah it's not
too fast back here cuz all the fan boy
is she did we got a you get we got a
five I don't even know that is Canadian
real sites take vitamin D shouted see
black rider slow boback's laughs finally
he said the following things are trash
decima men since 2003 stated a caged
juggernaut edition still a fix bugs its
launch and of course the Frostbite edges
or he go ahead busy you go there dizzy
for that what else we got deck so we got
dicks
we got this house of HD with the $10
super jet this is real ish people out
here NYC acting a fool which it was
still cold so all of us can live to see
more days in our legacies yeah people
look people are stupid like that my mom
we keep it real people are just know
people don't shout out they'll be money
one on one file a suits a salute to the
lords and my brother
aim can't wait to see what you got
cookin my man be money in a building
yard II know man
salut salut shot the Ray said Jerome
Bettis was gonna cover a game day 98
I remember game II that's crazy man you
know tremendous history man we got some
show to get into man this is hilarious
Fame bringing back the feels today you
say bro let's get this poll poppin you
know I'm saying last week poll is also
in and two people have spoken to the
question with the latest rumors
surrounding halo in its features which
of these elements are most important to
you for the title on xbox series X the
winner of the four-way il pepole with
52% of the vote was the narrative halo
story must be epic group coming at
second place at 23% was infinite on the
series X need to sell a huge graphical
difference group coming in at third at
17% of the vote was game mechanics hey
Neil infinite needs to do something
different group and coming in last place
at only 5% was I don't care if that
multi player eight pop in 343 is in the
bushes group do all the lords who
participated Lord Fame I need your
thoughts on this man what's the most
important thing to you for halo infinite
that story gotta be right and what what
whatever throw them we're T's we better
get because o halo 5 what we was teased
we didn't really get all right talk
about it reposed to get this big hunt
down remember the vision exit eight yeah
talk about all that was possible now and
what we did we got a left hook or right
hook a broken Bozza and that was it
that's all it was what we thought would
be so the story got to be on point and
it has to be but but it did show you
that you know if if walk wants to step
up to Master Chief you're gonna get down
Master Chief we go get it to these
topics man we got a good show going on
so Lord addict you are up man lot of
stuff going on in the Xbox world we got
some game passing some some some series
ex revealing what you want tackle first
brother what you want hit up man let's
let's do the the game pass numbers
so was officially confirm that Xbox has
ten plus million active subscribers on
game paths they said some nonsense about
to go about xbox live which you know
that could be anything
yeah million yeah it's still a high
number and I would say probably half of
those paid for maybe a little bit more
than that but you know let that
information we don't have but we do know
that ten million plus people or in-game
pass yes this off so pretty much I just
double down on what you said ten million
up ninety million active that's a 42
percent increase from last year's all
over live from 63 and yeah they also
touted the project exhale gaming
streaming service with hundreds of
thousands of users actively testing its
new service so let's get this round the
Lord the round table off a man um real
quick so what do you think about this
number you know are you excited like
about gamepad specifically yeah I mean I
know a lot of people who aren't they
call no rinsing games or the case may be
made and I think the bigger game pass
did that's the more money being funneled
into these developer Sam's which allows
them to buy more games think about it
miss expressing the time movie right now
bumpy brain got a job let alone being
able to drive sixty dollars on on a game
so they got game pass race important
game pass they can play you know a
hundred post titles so emotional
problems we got the moment the desert if
you're not think that was a losing money
she'd not lose the money they they would
put them in the right time cut you a
check will say in a lot of zeros I want
to bring up that you're saying to fame
is like there's more than just one
streaming service to like they can
literally go over here to to Xbox are
you me going gamepad for three months
they get all game pass they get that
check
and then they take that same concert
your PS now what are you going to pay me
for that I'm taking right now get your
baby so you know what it is and then
after after they do PlayStation now they
can hit up Google and then what they use
three streaming platforms are probably
paid for their development of their game
and pay for price per game but the
developer entrepreneur that you do it so
game fans it does two things you have to
developers and they help save some money
in the game with pockets mm-hmm I want
to say that things double by next year
though I want to be big as possible
because it's a win-win for everybody I'm
glad you said that friend because a lot
of people don't realize a game shop do
we had a Stephen Denton two tons studios
if I'm doing the UH on to the end and he
made it very clear it's like they
basically explain it is they give their
projection of Microsoft gives me
projection to them of what they think
the game's gonna do and you get your
bread as a developer up front so it's up
to you to accept it or not if you don't
based on you feel your worth or whatever
so this is something that gives them
that financial security right and then
they can just breathe and then work on
the game or whatever and it comes out
when it comes out you would say some
song orgy chirping no no okay sorry
so um yeah so that's the first
misconception so again we have to shut
down these narratives that we see that
if a game a game is on game pass that
you're not helping the devil that you
have to go buy the game to truly help
together if you choose to do it because
you are physical absolutely respected
but as far as this narrative of saying
it's not helping out that that's false
but just what they kind of find out with
that let's give our first wouldn't seek
actively seek to write games on game
pass if it wasn't benefiting financially
business baby
developers tell me the bank because they
want their game ball game pass yet no
David Serling he does a fantasy strike
yes
mmm-hmm I was talking to him and
wondering I interview before he was like
I'm sorry don't gain past I said what
it's no an xbox a now I'm trying to they
want their games on me run it exactly
then you got the hold exposure thing the
store front again these other games on
side of the next right next to the same
store space with the big
it's a huge benefit and then you gotta
think after like a year or not mm-hmm
all right bro
so song let's jump it right quick man
what you feel like this this users day
it's a sad I mean if the numbers are
fantastic right but and it's a sad thing
to say but the the current situation
world is in put a big microscope on why
game pass is important and why it works
because it's like Fame said like you
people can't go out and buy $60 game
right now right you know so if it's
something that you've already had and
you invested in or you managed to get on
board for a dollar like a lot of us did
you know however long ago when it when
eight when they first sort of introduced
everything it's it's a win-win situation
there's no negatives to it in fact then
like you said like the fact that
Christopher disagree he says some
Microsoft losing money the devs are
getting on someone got to the streets of
rage you lost money
[Laughter]
you just can't understate the value of
it and the fact that like you said a
game past what it does is is it brings
these smaller developers like when you
look at how many people how many outlets
reviews free trades for it was
eye-opening to me I said wait a minute
like there's a real excitement around I
thought it was ask the retro go to it I
honestly thought it was just gonna be
some the bigger outlets doing it just
because the streets are raised before we
haven't seen the street raise game for
30 years and the fact that you have so
many outlets reviewing it and so many
people hire on I said wait a minute and
I'm not saying it's game passes it's
because a game pass right but the fact
of the matter is how many people are
gonna go out there and purchase the game
for twenty five thirty dollars in the
current situation that we're in mmm-hmm
how many people went and picked that
game up on game pass and were able to
experience it and be able to talk I talk
about these positive experiences it's
just there there is no better situation
to exemplify the pluses
game pass in the situation that we're
currently in and in in weights it's kind
of genius because the thing is now
moving past this situation right game
passes on everybody's mind like what
what are we gonna be getting right and
another thing that we haven't touched
upon yet is that it was made official
the X cloud is going to be part of games
how it's official I understand it is
official it's official it will be part
of game past we don't know if it's gonna
be additional money whatever but what we
assumed it would be that it will today
be rolled into it in some way shape or
form right the hope and the expectation
is that there's no additional cost to it
and now that would proliferate game
paths even more there's nothing negative
to say about it I just want to make sure
that JW you heard that right no shout
out the city Smith mm which at bayonets
are you ready on your kings cover it we
got it we got you oh so because you got
cut off um you wanted to say something
about the game pass situation I'm doing
so much stuff over here I don't even
remember what I was good many no rush it
is this tight
you said you guys out here sticking your
chest last game last generation about
buying all your games are calling
PlayStation guys gave like geeks now
look at y'all bust they gonna early kick
they ready they ready what something is
like wow what do we say what did I tell
you I tell you those numbers was looking
funny under the light right I was
telling you as I was telling you
yo 19 million 90 y'all let the sink him
and let that wash over you let let just
stand in the rain and let that wash over
you let that game pass in the xbox live
wash over you a drench yourself in the
Lincoln wrenching itself fearless Oh
pause I want you I want you to feel this
because 90 million you guys is out here
on Xbox only still 35 million it's 90
million dudes done got that live I don't
know what their gaming on but it's 90
million dudes is residual income this
this is a
check this is a residual check every
month every quarter every REO your man
is right back at the rear is 90 million
at the rear now we ain't gonna get to
PlayStation our numbers or PlayStation
subscription numbers I want to know if
it balances out with your books I want
to know if it's 125 million in 125
million half because if it's only 35
million Xbox is out though 50 million
Xbox menu out there and it's 90 million
sold somebody's buying ghost phantom
systems and ghost phantom lives the
money is real nobody's losing money
that's why you got game pass this is
what happens when you get your butt with
this is what happens when you get your
but what you pull out all the stops game
pass 10 million people have game paths I
don't care if it was $1 and then we know
it wasn't a bunch of $1 dudes but let's
just say all of its 10 million dollars
right 10 million dollars
people got game paths and these games
has come and date and date people are
begging to get inside game packs why do
you feel that you're losing when I'm
winning I feel it's a win when I can
just anticipate a date and don't worry
about anticipating a bill it's like
going to your favorite restaurant and
you know there is Taco Tuesdays I'm
going in and get my food I'm gonna eat
and I'm gonna leave but you decide to
pay for your food why didn't you get on
a service like me this game past its
Xbox they out here doing it for us this
is for us this is not for nobody else
because let me tell you going into the
next generation with the series X we
know for a fact that anybody that has
game paths is going to get those games
date and date on release
there's no rush on those games because
those people are having fun inside game
paths why wouldn't you get in this
that's just my opinion over when the
numbers came out it was shocking to me
and my wildest dream
I cannot believe 90 million Xbox Live 10
million game pass no I would think of
something like probably two million game
paths probably Xbox Live was like sixty
this is shocking people I was told it's
more than ten million that that ten
million was supposed to be announced a
long time ago but this whole t-virus
thing interrupted all news outlets like
that so they held on to it for a little
bit
mmm that's that's all I got on it yeah
those are supposedly numbers before this
quarantine so if these are numbers
before the quarantine that is rose
that's not supposedly these are numbers
before Co control imagine during the
quarantine right now and when people
don't have it financially to go out and
do certain things and they're looking at
their situation they said well you know
what I could buy a game pass for these
months until I can get back to work or
doing whatever and all the family is
getting a chance to play games and
everybody's getting a chance to enjoy
and you're getting a chance to try stuff
wouldn't you be more likely to keep that
around it
what company held you down during this
situation that's the question that you
have to ask yourself I'm I'm confident
that a lot of these people you know
people like to talk about the hardcore
you know even the attic or hahaha but
you know we got to keep in mind that a
lot of these casual people you know when
they get onto this service like you know
the the the the mom that that's a
waitress that works 40 hours a week or
you know the the grandmother that's on a
fixed income that has a grandchild like
a lot of these people they would rather
just pay ten to fifteen dollars a month
and not have to buy $60 okay you know
Timmy I said can I have call of duty
well what's on game path there you go go
my son won't game Pass and you're
getting the games of gold every month I
don't know man I'm just I haven't seen a
value like this for me right and there's
something to be said that all you got to
do is go browse the menu and click
install wait for it to install and then
you try it something he said about that
you can find something for you
doesn't matter what type of gamer you're
there's something on there for you but
we're gonna talk about the games we'll
go again cuz I'm games dated on my arm
don't mention that you know you know
okay you know the reason why I mention
the fame because alright so my son has
game pass right and he looks through the
game pass list and I say but wait
there's more
you know this is this is a little extra
sprinkle in and then he saw I think it
was um last month it was like project
cars yeah he saw project cars and he was
like what's that is there like Forza I
said is a little deeper than Forza
he loves it it's amazing to him because
he's experiencing this for the first
time yeah so when you say somebody get a
chance to is nothing wrong with a little
extra sprinkles on the top means maybe
you might not like the springs please
don't put no sprinkles on my joint this
month I don't like the street keep it
dirty little black sprinkles off of it
please I don't like the chocolate
sprinkles good I like I like the rainbow
sprinkles please oh but it's just extra
it's just extra well we got a ton of
super chance Connor would not hear you
at all yeah you're talking but nothing's
coming out anyway look what's the last
Super chat that we got on so because
apparently something's going on with a
stitch yeah we got a bunch of super
tests to get through stitch 66 69 today
is rigged away day who is going to win
next week brother
yeah Z black rider with the $2 Canadian
dollar super chat ffs take vitamin D say
twice alright next we have Smitty Smith
for the two dollar super check bayonets
up captain gamepad who did that boy
billions and billions
laughter yeah we got a bunch okay in
November I don't think they're gonna do
that no no cog will ever put his knees
up no you have to bend the knee and he
wants you to bend the knee with the I
like they don't they're not gonna want
to put like the next with the follow us
which came past as an extra revenue
stream marinate on that game pass sauce
then we have this thing is flying fly
below what the heck on this thing okay
hold on
that's clutch ma what's man yeah okay so
yes I got the clutch man with the two
glasses which I set out to your guests
fame
larry's what's your set out to
Marionnaud Pumbaa with the $5 a good
chat Lord King spoke you gotta buy I
just gotta try my Sunday so we gotta
fight off super chat for one bad butter
only thing that tastes better than Taco
Tuesdays free Taco Tuesday 10 million in
as a mind share tipping point give yep
we got a fight out super chop from JD
gamer can't get them mm-hmm get them
famous y'all game pass equals Xbox is
winning and winning bigots I'm pretty
sure you said bigots I don't know
winning is those are game passed
straight are winning has tech saved my
podcast Jesus I thought you meant
pockets but okay we'll go with that we
gotta fight out super charm smoothies
with a Chris Hart
you ain't collecting these that's the
book of X on your neck from JT gamer
fame fame I'm getting visions of the
tick have you come through to drop a few
nuggets my brother what was the date
what was the day again famed 11th Bobby
laughing next month
James Twitter on five that out to P
Diddy Papa Papa Diddy puff Microsoft and
sing again real close Reese I love to
see that 10 million super-impressive
doing lights get moves like favor say oh
yeah man you know ten million man is
super impressive you know we know they
work and it's transparent when the NPD
stuff came out on the hardware so my
whole thing was always ok we know you
push and engagement we know you pushing
game pass could you please tell us the
numbers could you please let us know
what's going on because a lot of people
thought it was fraud in a lot of people
I know what that this thing is not doing
well you know I'm saying so for them to
come out and put these numbers out it's
a fantastic look and you know how I knew
the game pass was doing numbers what's
up
in GTA v when and that yeah because I
was like that that is something that
that they sell easily every month right
that's something Microsoft had you put
the back of the truck back up for and
that's something that I don't think
Microsoft will do unless they saw the
return everything at the end of the day
Phil cannot convince Sasha to do
anything if it's not it's not
financially viable also so it's very
saying such as with this I do wanna make
a point for a lot of people if you're
saying oh it's that much because it's
for a dollar it's only a dollar for the
first time you everybody think I'm
getting four dollars you already kind of
$4 before you make it before down the
game yeah yeah you can't get a dollar
again but it has to be like a long time
after you got it but once you in listen
I'd tell the truth man it's like you are
absolutely in an ecosystem where it is
completely consumer friendly I don't
care what anybody say if you can go out
there and purchase a brand new game same
day me you walk outside same day you go
purchase a game you say man I got this
filter for twenty-five fifty and keep
your filter my guy I will wait for the
download the moment and I'm gonna
definitely have fun over here but you
want something car really you onto
something
this is this is a business nobody trying
to do nothing if ain't about making
money the same thing now with it with
the game developers like Fame said like
they're not going to give Microsoft
their games away that's not how this
work you know they they gotta get pay
for so you know your card for some extra
question
all y'all was when Microsoft need to
release those numbers they stopped Heidi
because they're losing they stop putting
her now you got the numbers with your
mouth your mouth facto and still film
himself said it on Twitter like he was
like you he's like we're listening to
y'all we know that you guys want
transparency here you go like not more
than a few days and after that these
numbers come out which they had never
released before never released those
before and lasted thing because again
and for the people again wanna fighting
they're very hard
again I get it MPD means a lot to a lot
of people and you see it something at
the hardware aspect I get that part but
even Yashida said you mimic what Phil
said like yo engagement any subscription
services is the new way that's the new
metric right so this is what they're
gonna be giving you and it looks like
they're they're doing pretty good on
that sorry Christopher Hart okay what's
up
I guess the thought mm-hmm GTA is
removed out of game pass hahaha been
there for so long it's removed out of
game pass if you haven't played GTA
sorry but the goat is going inside gain
pass is pushing out the old goal for the
new goal and it's not like Dave
replacing it with something equally if
not as great so stop acting like game
passes losing any value you can't take
out one King and put another king in
sign and say they lost they didn't lose
anything
okay I got a cut where's the energy for
when you wat you your Netflix and they
take Avengers end game out after a
certain while you don't say where's the
energy when you don't know I'm gonna
know where does I'm gonna go straight to
new Playstation and that's the thing
like that's the thing you those first
party games are never leaving game past
first parties are never leaving game
past not so for PS now why would you
take a walk out of here same energy
that's not how we gotta August and the
fanboy stuff we have fun but we got it
the same energy that's unfair to be like
oh they took it out talk about that they
talk about all these other things
they've been taking it as well we gotta
call it down a line continued chaos up
yeah it's just the fact that you can't
think there's something that's not their
own is gonna last forever it's just not
but you can you can stayed in work don't
worry if you if you say Gears was
leaving right and you be like oh no
you're going against their right okay
cuz they stay promise day and date first
running up first parties leave it any
like yo what's going on yeah said XYZ
then we got a beef right we got a legit
because of what y'all from and I think
that's their that's their end game they
that's why they bought all these Studios
they want to give you games like gears
taxes they want to give you games like
fable like hey look like the actual gear
series they want to give you more
diverse library stuff like Psychonauts
keep people in this
ecosystem forever never leave let's get
these super chess element appeal to
dollar super catchall eight exciting
scene in Vegas with Elvis poop on a
messy bed do you want Louis - Oh super
chair I was supposed to cancel Netflix
eight years ago
fat girl getting on that they are
banking on people not kids
nobody times I look at my reoccurring
take it from someone that worked a DISH
Network that I I probably had 15 20
calls every day it's like your how do I
cancel my Netflix I'd say the same thing
oh yeah well you'd probably want to call
Netflix I mean that's probably the best
ways to go man it is what it is but we
had a before in the second part
obviously back so me a big announcement
attic in obscene Xbox series X the games
on May 7 at 8:00 they did clarify it it
was a little camp yeah they said
Microsoft will include every next-gen
game play for Microsoft's global
development partners so Xbox game
studios will gig Xbox game studio games
will not be showcased at this for a
later date and they said Greenberg got
on a he's pumped to see the partners
showing that there's a xbox series X
game playing next week they got more
plans they said more details soon on
Microsoft's own plans after that so want
to bring this to the realm Laura Fame
now that we've got a date you know I'm
saying for the global partner games how
do you feel about this approach from
above Xbox you know I'm okay with it
you can I think a lot of people leaving
out a simple fact that even though these
are partners that doesn't mean we won't
get Xbox exclusive or Microsoft
exclusive in this section some people
will let all I want to see what they got
exclusively coming right there's not
like there aren't second or third party
deals now you look at dote notch tell me
why that's Xbox kudos their party studio
but isn't exclusive so not cool with
this no one that later on we're gonna
get to see what almost every first
particle was doing that's great and I
think this kind of filters out something
so we're not having to worry about
alright here's Marcus on Savannah right
was that exclusive what was that it's
cool what was that we know off forever
pal we don't have a nice gravelly be us
articles from journalists Oh turns out
this game is really is multiplied with
ribeye that's an away y'all know that
you could want to this event gonna be
mostly mostly plants but I almost
guarantee you want to give one to lease
to Lowe's games you're gonna be
exclusive to the - long well I don't
want people game pass up right quick for
kissable to awesome chat they are
replacing GTA 5 with Red Dead Redemption
to Xbox game pants gotta throw in my
work for more now what next one y'all we
missed what's the next one
we got JD gamer with the $10 super check
come on my Lords I know y'all been
running around Twitter collecting news
nothing right
that energy is so off those games has
numbers on their backs back old 10mil
are not fake probably a good amount of
them that's on that dollar a month thing
but like and not everyone thinks like
like Kofi like BG like not not bheegi
bheegi don't do these subscription
services a lot of people that get the
free month they study with the game with
the sure there are some people that just
want to ride that way and you know play
for free for a month but that I'm you
know it's like I said I used to deal
with people like this all the time a lot
of people stick with the service it's
not like you know a lot of these
personas on Twitter wants you to think
that them like everyone is getting the
dollar everyone is not only getting the
dollar but they're cancelling after the
dollar my kid how it goes yeah bets out
the pixel bit G - Alison Pichette Xbox
is so so confident they putting out two
shows interesting interesting
yeah we gotta get those on next ones man
I'll get the next one John Luther super
chat the only series X rival is a
high-end PC bout down so we got a $5
super cell from John Armstrong's I have
a gaming PC Xbox one X and ps4 pro I
only use the pro for exclusive but my
heart is definitely what the Xbox we
won't mention the connective you know
what
on our strum you are completely onto
something Kinect doesn't exist let's say
oh yo shout out to connect yo yo Fame I
was buy-in a bail draft and I saw the
Commissioner he had a connector auto if
you caught that favor he's never in this
is broke I saw Roger Goodell yous out
there was already shaking with his
connect with remember the partnership
that market assault area with the NFL
yeah heard that's cooking man but I'll
continue we was up to on this old giant
oh did I interrupt her up somebody was
talking about the Oh an addict yes a
toccata robot you as far as your um
series X reveal when it comes to I do
think fames onto something I think you
know probably won't be I think there's
at least one game of those that they're
they're going to announce this an
exclusive for the place they she's
probably gonna be represented under
their global brand you know the global
things that they do they might surprise
this with like a teaser at the end of it
that's like a teaser for fable or
something like five second it's got to
shut you down
Lord McCaffrey he put out the tweet he
was just like noon he said I'm seeing a
lot of good hard a fake Xbox fan who
seem to think Microsoft's gonna pull a
fast one and surprise a reveal halo or
another first party games next week they
are not expecting any first party
content on May 7th will wholly lead to
your own self-discipline the point miss
appointment he said the last thing he
said look it's a bigger pressure friends
they've been doing a great job messaging
this console so far it's all build up
the name the reveal the specs to
demonstrate the features to third-party
games he said first party games will
come then price and say so you just kind
of say a hold the line let's not get hot
that they would even even even do that
you know we gotta be greedy we want all
of it we want a soup we want the Y we
want everything I want that stuff that
King was eaten last night but I kept my
shrimp pepper shrimp
yourself we gotta get these super
Chesbrough we still high we got stitch
okay Armstrong okay stitch stitch with
the file a super chat first show fill
put in the boot on the second
put the boot on second show for putting
the boot on the neck and the book exhale
hop in book exon HSI submitted ad gaming
with the file a super attack
Microsoft is so slick they found a way
to make PC pay game pass baby could you
possibly pass it up and now they got PC
players in the Windows Store captain
captain cash flock crisp heart reporting
for duty man that was a tongue twister
the captain caps lock Chris Hart
reporting for duty
I got you need to read that real quick I
need you yeah Mike oh yeah their five
best I find his father okay okay Michael
okay best our finest the Jesse j-dub
captain's saying 1 million PSN make more
than game past 10 Meghan King put j-dub
in this place I don't have to I don't
have to because nobody asks me no more
on Twitter
nobody not a soul put some they don't
invoke this spirit upon them you know I
tell you right now they understand
exactly who filled nominees maximus soon
to be a really as is they know exactly
now you know the warrior you're fighting
in this battle so when you understand
that this show coming up and they show
in games they say yo this is how a
general move this is how a leader moves
I'm gonna showcase yo stuff first
you have been gracious enough to bring
your stuff to my platform i'ma put you
in the right light see did see not only
did he put gamers first now he's putting
his second party girls first those
developers first sure game and none of
our games to be there this is about you
guys
this is a celebration of you guys at the
same time this is a pincer move oh right
because this is forcing Sony to say we
got to show something they all has
showing love to developers in this time
right
now we develop a need light on their
games you want to know where these games
is going to be played so if these games
are played first and shown first on a
Microsoft platform where do you think
those games in in the layman's heads
game um do you think they really the
casuals really feel that Valhalla is
only on an Xbox series or something you
might be right so when they when you
hear actual gameplay from a series X oh
oh this is exactly what I'm getting hmm
this is it right here I always try to
tell people people like to to overlook
what a marketing Dell can do for you
like they do they try to act like you
know The Last of Us and you know
uncharged and Halo and stuff so this may
be that many
you know what sells more than anything
ever Call of Duty oh yes the fact that
when you are Superbowl when you're
watching Super Bowl Sunday and you see
at the very end of that commercial say
PlayStation 4 they don't have to say
only on PlayStation you know Jimmy over
there watching that that's trying to
look for something to get this
grandchild for Christmas to say oh if I
want call the duty I got to get a
PlayStation you don't know no better
exactly now I want you to think about it
this way right this is where the pencil
move works in this is waiting for
somebody hand to make them do something
that's how you smack somebody in the
face and see if they're gonna react
right so that we already know they got
smacked in the face they had to do the
fake GDC joint there you already know
they got smacked in the face right after
that and they had the reveal of
controller they didn't want to reveal at
that moment right so now they're gonna
get smacked in the face again right now
having him smacked in the face for real
this time
now you got a reveal your system and you
got to reveal some type of gameplay but
where I put a lot of pressure on them
but myself did right they raised the
stakes the stakes was raised when they
showed you a breakdown and it we've
never seen no tear above a system until
it comes out until it gets to our house
then you feel out what's inside they
showed you what was inside ahead of time
the level of confidence is exuding from
fill Dominus Maximus Spencer soon-to-be
Aurelius
this man I've told y'all before he's not
a nice guy you thought he
cold-blooded killer cold-blooded because
this is moves of somebody who's going
for your face no all right so listen
so what Microsoft did was they put an
impending brick above their head
this is the impending brick they told
you this first show has nothing but game
play games from you know Xbox joining
this second party moves and stuff like
that
none of our stuff is there but we're
doing another show at a later date
depending on the fool who act up if you
act up you're fitting to get smacked up
so okay so now the Sony has to release
their console they got the show make
model design mm-hmm they got to give a
teardown because if they put it out
there and be like this is the box and
walk away you're gonna be like nah my
man right that ain't it okay so then you
gonna say where's your games that don't
because now the reason ass take that why
are they playing behind but then
Microsoft still has the anvil on their
head if they'd play wrong
and each I swear if they play wrong and
they try to jump out the window
Microsoft is watch that date get pushed
up and anvil hit them right back in the
head to put them right back into place
guys Steve Jess we got some chats man we
got it we got we got a Z black rider
with the final a super check good day I
always pictured attact as a sexy twitch
stream my cameraman how's it going woman
great game game is so low Saturday's you
already know so put some of the ladies
in a realm you already know what else
hold on it jumps me all in one second
the element of you
I got trigger man which everyday my bad
mister you right you correct trigger man
without a super chat what time will Sony
still Xbox limelight again JD with the
$10 super jet Sony was out here arrogant
as ever turning their backs on Indies
first then turning it back on double-a
and all the rest of their partners
skipping events since 2018 now look what
it's Costin hashtag humble pie no doubt
and then last one elemental peal file so
much as Sony will show you what's in the
passion instead of a console breakdown
so that element appeal man look I'll
finish this up real quick King killed it
a lot of great points um look I was kind
of at first I go for now I felt the way
because I was like okay smooth don't
pull it up it's lit your joint to the
side
slide that over to the left probably the
front I was in my feelings I didn't know
a little bit exactly did you talk to be
on your an issue was my initial feeling
to like but then I thought about our I
king is awesome because I was like
alright Sony still haven't revealed any
plans yet for the most people obviously
we just got the controller and we gonna
skip the super chat you guys can't catch
up tell me how it goes say for $5.00
they need to put work at it as a
playable character but we gotta get that
adding DLC for room yes I thought about
I'll just like look man at the end of
the day the competition has not shown
much so why reveal your hand all of your
hand right when you gotta see what they
go and do so this is this is this is tak
this the auto world right gotta see what
the opponent gonna do
so that part right there number two I
was like look like I'm solve you said
there's no III there are parties don't
have a place right now this is a show
the industry right huge only sold for
Microsoft to say look
bring your whiz to our joint on our
stage you're saying like that that's a
good move you know and let's keep it a
buck man as much as we love or the
exclusive content on both cars on all
consoles right the third party stuff is
what really moves things things so you
want to show people you're gonna show
all valhalla
you show it in the best possible light
on console that has it you know it has
to deal with as well teraflops yeah I'ma
be honest man I don't know if this is
what their cadence was to begin with or
just because they've been forced to do
everything digitally right I think it's
it's perfect like the way way Xbox has
talked about the console reveal then
should own the
having to break down little by little
and it's gonna give them it's gonna give
them stuff to show off the entire year
and wait it doesn't feel like like we're
ever starving for information not forget
you know I'm about to get what he told
you said we're third party but selling
the best but here's the thing again we
have to stop thinking about ourselves I
said this out to Crossfire's on Friday
we got to start thinking that because
we're the hardcore that our voices are
the loudest because they're not at the
end of the day like an excited best
there are so many people who watch it in
man and they see whether it be mad and
call of duty or whatever this Assassin's
Creed Valhalla and they see on one stage
and they see a logo at the end right oh
that's what is only on xbox oh that
joint is only in one place that's it
that's the car even if they don't
subconsciously put it only on that
platform
they they they connect it to that
platform because they're seeing it for
the first time you will that play your
card what's up haven't we saw saw
anytime is on that Summer Jam screen
it's in game pass so no isn't that
sometimes it's it's every game that they
have shown has wound up inside game pass
now on the seventh this is the double
sword he wants treat all of these games
now you can get them date and date when
they come out oh you can sit back and
wait in this marinate and they're gonna
show up in game pal do you mean
unfortunately no I got you okay don't
you bet like all those go there that no
no I get to get this time so we sit
there talking like damn I should have
waited because it ended up going
together I'm never gonna forget Devil
May Cry so that's gonna break my very
gift it's not gonna happen then that
January I looked up I said what the hell
are they talking about this is our game
pads I didn't get a chance to bout it
and I ran and I downloaded they're
stubborn he said casuals follow the
hardcore said told ya we set the tool
but casuals not all casuals have access
to hardcore their castles would just
watch stuff and what they see is
thinking is what they going to get so
again we have to stop conflating that we
are the hardcore that are voices but I
will say that because there are certain
scenarios more hardcore or
the casual now I do think I do think at
the behave of gin that is important
because we're the ones going out buying
the consoles and I'm convinced to my
roommate that's a Casio get the Xbox
just let because I got it he's seeing it
you know it's it's it's state of mind
that that really helped me but here's my
last point and I'll give it over all
right I know kids in a building you
jumped out first we come back but on
look the last point is I got a shablow
Adobe on Twitter ban he said it he said
it's so good he was like look think
about this Xbox has enough first party
that they can do their own show think
about that right they they can do a
whole segment on just first party and
now they're doing this with this third
party show so well I'm coming around on
your pencil approach keep it got to mean
something you have said you you have to
have enough offerings to be able to do a
full show of just your first party and I
think that's the reason they they
because you know they they spent a lot
of money on these call on these studios
right it regards that they build a
studio cuz you know a lot of people just
want to point out you know the
playground etc etc but it's not just
that playgrounds got three Studios ninja
theories got three studios they made us
you're dedicated to the age of empire by
the way you can't do a whole show or
just ground into the games that people
thinking today told hey you know they
know they're not gonna show ground it
again I'm not going there they're not
gonna show grow they did that or it but
they gotta give us some light if it's
close to believe though show will is
coming out listen they're not gonna show
ground it at that did the next Xbox join
the next X particularly definitely gonna
show ground right five years and why did
they show Co threes because see see if
thieves because the millions and
millions of people was planning and they
had to tell keep a horn because that's
how we don't forget how we got millions
and millions you always clowning me your
thought was it go a joke and then who
you know what that was a Freudian slip
[Laughter]
to go see things out here still banging
in the streets again we got to see
what's going on I have no problem on it
that's all I got what the time we kind
of killing it a little bit some light
but kid jumped out we got to move on man
look make this quick cause obviously
everyone know what's going on as far as
you know I felt like this talk is going
to be the longest let's try to make this
quick well you know the situation you
know I'm saying as far as the last
trusted leaks is you knows please
Twitter is spooky out their social media
spooky if you're going out there be
careful oh this whole lot of things are
being sleek clapboys and all that stuff
look all I want to say is our subdue
information came out um
shout out to Sony they put a jump in
front of it they said that the leaker is
not an employee they know who it is you
know I'm saying and then there was a
couple of stories running around you
know that would kind of been debunked
saying that you know there was it was
definitely employee and all this other
stuff so I won't bring it to the Lord so
you don't say in reference to the leak
in the saga you know real quick which I
got feeling about it and with the latest
information that you guys heard more
fame you are up what are you feeling
about this thing right you know somebody
I'm not allowing I first heard that it
was a it possibly could have been a
disgruntled employee I'm a lot kind of
laughs I'm like man you gotta ruin Joe
career buddy like my mom might what
person would kind of go their entire
career in the frame there's no other
developer no other company would ever
touch you with you right Janelle we hear
that that was a that was a hack I mean I
guess we kind of used a sonic in hacked
at this point but I kind of see that
more as a viable option of I believe
more than Sony was act well somebody's
hacked into a naughty dog some old game
and a dog and I D I believe that more
then some guy a girl decided to throw
the entire career in the trash right
because they're because they're upset so
I do kind of believe in the porch now
for two reasons
for real way into I mean that the first
time somebody got into Sony I might
would take you felt like I feel I don't
have man I mean what you got Atika you
know the whole situation that we've
talked about it at nauseam look I don't
do I think this is going to like
drastically heart last of us know I
think for the most part you know people
are going to go into this and it's going
to do just as well as it did without it
but I do think that it will hurt the
cells a little bit it might hurt the the
reception because how I know something's
something's wrong is when I see people
on Facebook talking about it and I saw
probably 15 20 people on my personal
Facebook had an issue with these leaks
and I'm just thinking myself first off
why you even look at the leaks if you
want to play the game but that's besides
the point but you know there's a lot of
people with issues with expressly than
their to focus that's going on we won't
go over that but you know I do think
that it's gonna be issues for Sony do I
think it's gonna drastically hurt their
brand no the games still gonna be high
quality and it's still gonna review well
this might make you hit the 80 so but
we'll have to see exactly you know how
the reviewers like the game because you
know at the end of the day it's their
it's their opinions that matter when it
comes to you know Metacritic button
cells wise this this game's gonna show
like blockbusters there's nothing gonna
stop this the only thing that would stop
this is that they like something drastic
happened like you know but then Erica
brought up with a point when I said this
is gonna sell like blockbusters these
people are not gonna hold by the word
she's like that's what people said about
battlefield 5 mmm-hmm oh man we got we
got a lot o saw please it's mid GT
ya know Christopher Hart first where is
it Christopher Hart okay Christopher
Hart first PlayStation 5 reveal will be
a game over move yeah for you listen
Chris and
love you with all my heart man I'm not
gonna lie you come in here you sling
these arrows and you swing that bat for
Sony
god bless this is what I'm trying to
explain to you they're in a pincer move
no matter what they do no matter how
they move there are in the kill box it's
already there it's like you already
boxed in all right you're not doing the
box and they are getting boxed oh right
now you know you want the reveal is
it'll be a great thing for you but the
aftermath for when they step out of
place the brick is coming no that is the
brick coming you waiting for you waiting
for the Devin you want to see what's
going on looking at it series ass but
but then when that PlayStation get
revealed you still know that the next
show is coming and don't forget to
bayonet my guy but I'm sorry I just
don't see how you get out this kill by
I'm gonna see how they wiggle up magic
mark Cerny
needs to show some magic moves to get
out of that box pixel BG with the $2
super tech ps5 a real deep dive into God
fail and lack of r-tx Wow GOG podcast
because of a heart you mean like the
Sega Dreamcast from JD gamer Xbox out
here playing the Queen's Gambit move by
move sack by sack just crushing to the
end game we'll we'll see who's King is
still standing
hashtag checkmate Wow near-mint old Oh
bill meant a shout out to booms brothers
can we come together as a family and get
a crystal heart admitting there's a
problem no it's a vision to get your
stuffs working man people people want
you to get help that was that Oh
no mega mega triple zero 3000 with the
file all super chat how do you guys feel
about everyone hating the leaked plot of
the Last of Us - it's being trashed
everywhere is it fair for people to
judge the plot this early I think talk
about what they sure we might not know
everything on how such-and-such got to
such-and-such party and how this part
happened but if you know pretty much
like the highlights of game it you can
paint a decent picture of what's gonna
happen well yeah it can we paint the
whole picture of course not right but
it's like knowing the highlights of the
end game it's saying you can't predict
what's going to happen right it's also
context right you still have to see it
in the context correctly stuff like that
show the elemental peel file so chat
nothing wrong seeing a bootleg before it
comes to theater proper your fam yeah
out of control
Microsoft comes to a drop series X at
it's not just over Sony we might sell
them see them selling off buildings it's
a five again pick someone kills hashtag
oh my lord
messy out here crazy who was up got was
him talking about I'll say like I said I
what what leaks I don't know what the
heck they don't exist to me I mean look
taking these things out of context I
already knew like and I've said this a
bunch of times already
The Last of Us is a game that did not
need a sequel I'm happy to see I'm happy
to see it I'm gonna play it yeah and I'm
and I'm excited to play it um this was
gonna always be a game that was gonna I
was gonna rub people the wrong way right
because in it when you look at the
setting in that world
and and the type of story they're trying
to tell you it is absolutely a reality
that the characters you grow accustomed
to being close to and caring about will
probably die in some way shape or form
right I don't know that that's the case
but it's it's almost guaranteed in that
type of world and the type of
storytelling that they're trying to sort
of do with these games yeah
things are gonna happen that your it's
not gonna be a happy-go-lucky ending
like you know you're not gonna get that
and I hate to say this man I was like a
dick can't help yourself
he needs to be on the cutting edge of
knowledge you guys I'm gonna tell you
this I know there's people to say you
know whatever the leaks don't affect I'm
still gonna play the game for me I
that's because yeah I care about that
story I care about how I feel in the
moment when some would I discover
something so to me that that's gonna
have a spoiler Castle eyes it was
because I could i coli the the leaks may
be that I'm gonna play the game now like
the leaks made now I was game I was
playing the game regardless is the
triple-a banging it is by you know Sony
it's a single in the corner joint let me
let me jump in real quick because um dis
is Sony's fault and let me tell you why
it's so nice for you
don't you love how he know it's it's
Sony's fault because they had the
opportunity to put that game out
digitally before all this happened
before all of this happened and they
postponed it indefinitely now I'm real
good at smelling BS I mean I'm real good
at smelling a liar I have I have I
should have been a detective in my
because when something don't add up it
just don't add up
right so they gave you something that
was palatable that was Sony got hacked
now just like Fame said what we used to
Sony getting hacked that's plausible so
all you got to do is put plausible
deniability doubt in the jury's head for
you to get a hung jury mmm right so you
guys is like yeah that is possible Sony
doesn't have the great security mm-hmm
no I'm going with there was a
disgruntled employee you still go I'm
with the disgruntled employee for these
reasons and these reasons only sitting
here in this quarantine situation and if
I'm a developer that has been putting
bills on hold waiting for bonus when the
game goes out and then that bonus comes
in and I'm able to pay off some stuff
and I'm able to to get out of debt if
I'm the mortgage company is calling my
house I don't have any money coming in
I'm looking at my kids I'm looking at
everything that I worked hard for and
because a greedy corporation wants to
hold back because they want to get every
last dollar I can't hold on to the stuff
that I worked so damn hard for but you
know Adam let me explain a mentality of
an individual with his back up against
the wall
it's like a rabid dog you don't know
what the hell is going to happen from
that moment on but your level of
survival your your visceral I can't say
the word hate your disdain right for a
corporation that's those people are
still eating lobster and shrimp right
and you thinking about the prospect of
buying dog foods you don't know the
mentals because it has to be for
somebody to commit career suicide
know what is want you out the man you
know you know why you didn't out the man
why because it is no Manta out there
like day that you can't say that did not
wait they spoke see Jim Jackson Jim
Jackson we got him
okay we got we've got a bill that we
have one that in this community what
companies yo remembered I got any time
any time something has come out you know
likely cuz they give me like listen
hackers
yeah hackers are the most arrogant dudes
in the world lizard squad but that
doesn't mean that they didn't do listen
lizard squad be like yeah we did that
that your girl is dead or whoever this
dude is dead
Oh Tommy caught a bullet here you mad we
did that we made you upset right slow
hackers are the most arrogant and they
want to show you how godly they are
absolutely right
so what a corporation is going to do to
show you know you know they didn't work
for us
but we identified who the intruder was
who's an intruder my man if he don't
work for you what whoa why are you
holding his name back if he didn't work
for you he has nothing to do with your
company then why are you protecting him
because he didn't protect you all right
but okay I digress right hmm I'm gonna
buy the game anyway I don't care about
the leaks at all that has nothing to do
with I did not look up anything I don't
care cuz I come from a culture of I want
to play it right I don't wanna I wanna I
want to see this I'm going to I'm going
this is one of Sony's great bangers yeah
it's unfortunate that trolls is out here
sending it to people that don't want it
spoiled for them
now do I condemn the individual who did
it because he was a selfish individual
yes but do I understand at the end of
the day that I don't walk in your shoes
and I don't live in your world yes I do
brother but remember for every
consequence and for every action there's
a consequence right and you're going to
have to live through this concert oh man
the shot in fine art super check on PSN
2011 PSN hack card info stolen 2013
Sony's pictures hacked emails movies
info stolen then independent Netflix
20/20 hacked again Last of Us stole it
listen you know you may be onto
something with a security I'll give you
that you know saying but on look it's
just unfortunate you know saying at the
end of the day is just unfortunate with
the whole situation you know I was
surprised to see that much stuff leaked
out didn't like seeing it you know and
for the people who don't want to see it
just so flagrantly out there it's just
disrespectful you know the other day I
got
two issues though the issue are with you
King know is that we all know the game
we all know the game was delayed
indefinitely hmm I just struggled with
the fact that once the leaks are out now
you got a release date no they do have a
question for you without you know back
do you think that it's possible this was
a hacker that he hacked them because he
was upset because the game was
indefinitely delay does not know more he
got his point what they said it was
apparently that the hacker got in
through an exploit in another naughty
dog game and was able to access it
wasn't actually the game's length don't
smoke and what it was the net according
to them in rings I saw it broke they
broke into the network to an exploit in
another naughty dog game ok and let's be
real every these guys over a lot of
these guys are working from home it's
not as secure as the normal it is a
different climate with the whole virus
people are gonna hold you don't know
what the security situation is if it got
loose it got loose somebody maybe was I
don't know I'm not gonna speculate my
whole thing is I'm gonna care about that
mod thing is obviously I'm sad about the
whole situation get leaked obviously I'm
looking at the Mossad I don't with all
of a sudden you magically got a release
date when you told us indefinitely and
the other thing no one's talking about
it shout to my manhole or with these
copyright strikes they are giving
copyright strike Sony's giving copyright
strikes to youtubers who are just
talking about the leaks not it not
showing the leaks not not even reading
the plumb points of the leaks just
talking about the leaks so little hole
went in and this is this a corporate
lawyer he was like yo they violate
illegally using copyright takedown
laws they breaking they break it a lot
of violation and a lot of these
youtubers are going to fight back that
to me is an issue you know I get it you
try now it's gonna get sued you try to
do damage control but at the end of the
day you
cannot change the language of the law
because so what you're saying cut right
now
what's up when they when they read the
topics and they see that this is on deck
they can get us yeah okay so what I'm
gonna look you in the eye Sony listen
I'm looking at no no no no free
PlayStation now for life and I'll shut
up I'll just sit back I'll let your rock
I won't see nothing knows just hit him
on his xbox 360 level at the end of the
day that part I don't agree with you
know I'm saying that people going to
talk about as long as they're not
spoiling your plot points it's no
takedown notice there's no infringement
there there that's stretching a long
shot I get if you don't believe me y'all
think I'm lying I think I'm captain
please go to home law virtual legality
has it up right now this is a corporate
lawyer telling people that Sony is in
violation for what they're doing to
these youtubers leaked by someone take
down so you take it up with the lawyers
if you won't believe me go so how well
are you saying talking about the leaks
just I'm talking about like well right
now we according to Sony they are trying
to stretch DCMA law you know that it's
say that it's infringement and they are
rushing to take it down we don't these
guys don't have pictures they don't
underplay I don't understand if it was
like game players something but like how
you gonna hit someone just for talking
about stuff that you like Italy yes
Sony illegally using the copyright act
to stretch it to their you know
advantage in reference to this thing so
we got to see that's what I got a little
more saw you up the us a fast brother so
before we do that we have a bunch of
super check to get to we got restored
Hades with the file also but at I don't
think it's terrible that the game leaked
however what Sony's and nor the dog are
doing to youtubers is completely
unacceptable yep Nate you just talked
about that the living flame with a $2.00
super chat people will wait for reviews
for The Last of Us to now we got Cyrus
Burke well we asked MIDI Smith with the
$5 super Jack King is right about the
hackers just look at destiny on the PC a
word
they're the most arrogant light in the
world they want to put they they gotta
have their name known they want to put a
stamp on you and for you to say that
somebody hacked them and don't come
forward please hit that like button
please job then we got Cyrus burka to
file off super chat I'm sure nobody dog
is working on two games right now so why
would the hacker only leak one game
after the indefinite delay hashtag why
not both yes listen you're all starting
to buy into the Kings theory god bless
ya we got again with the $10 super chat
as for the person's career this person
may never be a game developer again that
doesn't mean they can't do something
else journalism reviewer or youtuber and
many more leaker is gonna be fine being
in the game industry I think that he was
at least smart enough not to get caught
in any shop emoji Lord's game he said
the multi player leaked oh yeah I saw
that too yes he's a professional Iike to
restore Hades I say have you seen Philip
mucin lately change his likeness and
your man's eye we're gonna have to like
what I'm more curious on is like if they
if it was a developer if anyone knows
who it was like everybody was because he
was talking in a water cooler and I see
my name say my name is he said go ahead
put my name in these streets and i'ma
tell everything someone game fest Geoff
Keighley back in the news after Jeff
Keely unceremoniously uh gave III the
boot saying that he was not on board
with what they were trying to do
and then making it clear that Gamescom
was going to be sort of the next time we
were gonna see him apparently in the
interim since obviously the world has
changed a bit and people were asking
them well Jeff what are you going to do
before games come is there anything I
Jeff initially said no I'm not doing
anything I'm just Gamescom is it um but
then he basically decided look I need to
find a way if I'm gonna be sort of the
face at the forefront of this sort of
digital movement of gaming and sort of
putting gaming under one big umbrella
where everyone around the world has
access to this to these events in a way
that's meaningful I have to do something
about replacing quote unquote III and
what he came up with was some a game
fests so basically some game fest is
something it is is a quote unquote
festival that's gonna run from May
through August so basically the same
time that we would see the big summer
gaming events III obviously Gamescom I
took your game show things like that arm
sort of kind of rolled into one but
spread out over a four month period
where he basically has gotten partners
throughout the gaming industry to be
able to show their wares to possibly
have some sort of digital online demos
of their games and basically digitizing
and and digitizing these events in a way
that makes them accessible to the entire
world which is what he what basically
his gripe with III um was that they were
it was focused on this one event that
wasn't globalized in any way it didn't
have something that Digital hand in hand
that people around the world can access
in a meaningful way and feel like they
were really a part of the event um so
this is something that he's been wanting
to do for a long time and I guess what's
going on in the world it's made it it's
made it easier to sort of bring that to
the forefront but we have some a game
fest coming from Geoff Keeley I'm
excited to see what it is
obviously the expectation is that
third-party publishers and the first
party publishers are also going to be in
on this in some way shape or form so
expect some sort of announcements every
single month from May to August
Lord Feynman you think man are you
excited for this summon game professors
think about it I first I want to say I
think it's safe to say between this and
the VGA s and every Lea has you know yep
well Jeff Healey has secured the bank
only easy
oh now becoming the face of video game
now almost like this is crazy
I don't know how this happened but he's
the face of game facts that's why I'm
about to get in my when I when I get him
up he's a powerful man right yeah I
didn't see this coming like I really did
predict like he would be over some show
that would announce a ps5 like Mel with
my heart heart saying we the last time
we see him he gonna be you know right
now so some type of show was Sony with
the PS fire review I didn't I didn't see
this coming and I'm out forward I may we
know big Rona it's not a destroy a lot
of stuff this year and the more video
game content we can get regardless of
the publisher regardless of the
developers regardless of the platform
the ball game if we get in our veins I'm
all the way for Geoff Keighley the
secured the bag and I'm sitting there
I'm sitting there like yeah go and do
something else cuz the more you give us
the better
a lot of people a lot of gamers aren't
able to go to the e3 is in the world or
there were during her time so we got a
visual event everybody can attend it's
gonna be lit by different pockets on me
it's gonna be held a live for four
straight months I'm all with it now let
me ask you this favor for passage do you
think if this pops off It's A Wrap free
three man Gotti the sound boss you can
play that that uh but not to take a
tombstone think about it think about the
millions of dollars these new companies
for the same and still get the word
early two-thousands you know or the
night is where you need to type of event
to get the word out to put magazines
information is at the tip of my fingers
now the social media we don't need to
have the Tribune to run me yeah I think
the best part of my bed is for the
gamers to get the girls where we can
meet up and kick it mother than that we
don't necessarily meet that big event
because the information I read my
fingers so if I'm a company why not save
a few million
yeah you gotta mean this doesn't
necessarily even apply to gaming man
like I've been saying just watching the
news there's plenty of companies who are
saying that the amount of productivity
and influx of money that they're seeing
during this period of time leading them
to cut their workforce by a certain
percentage and have people work from
home after this is all set and setting
up don't yeah so I have a building when
you can have them stay home exactly any
it's just it's it's a sign of the times
and what I like about Kiwi is that Kili
from the beginning he's saying I don't
even think the shows need to go away
right he's not saying that what he's
saying is that we need to create
something that works hand in hand with
it that is just as robust that everyone
has access to he's that cuz he's saying
he loves it he loves the show doesn't
love the fact that they're so isolated
if you want a mobile eyes gaming if you
really if you're really interested in
globalizing gaming how you do it right
yeah the thing about that you're right
I'd be the only thing though that he
said that troubles me as far as e3
future though is that you know he
according to childhood was a game that
happens I've got a sheet up in news guys
you know I got the article he was kind
of saying that he was presenting this to
the EC a to the ESA yes right and it
wasn't they were resistant and he wants
to make it global so my concern is that
if this pop off who's Elizabeth like
Fame say this man is super powerful he's
got all these major put everyone's
playing ball Microsoft Sony all the
third party the only one that hasn't
played ball so far that we don't know if
isn't intentional right every other
major third party everyone is in pocket
with some again Xbox themselves just
said they do with some summit games so
my thing is if this pops off like that's
the thing if you have then that's a
problem the ESA s stance on this has
always been pushing back on it like no
this is not what we want but at the same
time this is not what we want but yeah
we're gonna have people up entertained
by by celebrities online while they're
waiting to play this game for ten
minutes
whereas what would happen if after they
show gameplay of Valhalla
they're like download the demo right now
mm-hmm platform you're on download the
demo right now anywhere in the world
right do that only three you can't you
can but the thing about it is as much as
we see III as our mecca of gaming for
the year right indecent as global the
thing is we don't like to believe it is
right games Commons a far bigger it's a
far bigger winner work sofas or more
people exactly so what Akili saying is
as great as that is if you look at the
big picture it's not addressing the big
picture you know it's not addressing a
big picture the fact that these elitist
is trying to do it to us again so for a
long time we fought to get Assad III it
was only um if he was media if you was a
developer it was industry only get
fought very hard we got in so now that
we end and we're actually youtubers
influencers provocateurs is out here
getting the interviews they start to see
the control leave so the latest that was
eaten at the table they didn't like us
there they didn't like us in the same
room breathing the same air getting the
same level of content and sometimes
doing it better than you yeah my one two
step is way better than yours
and yeah you go put me on any platform
and I'll blow you out the water or God
in their laws so when you see that the
level of fear is how can I exclude them
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go at
the old regime first I'm gonna take down
the old regime which is the fun part the
zone the the FOMO the feeling of missing
out you have to be at III see it's
something to be said that when you got a
pack up go out and go to work right now
who's doing these interviews for they
digital
first only who's doing these interviews
talking to these deaf people that you
chose you ëletís people that you you
trying to freeze me out but at the point
do you think that you're gonna freeze me
out that's not gonna happen
oh it's not gonna happen because what's
gonna happen is you're gonna have us get
a coalition you're gonna have you are
embodying us to get the coalition
together to remove you because the same
way you remove them it's going to be an
overthrowing of you you're not gonna
handpick your intervene individuals to
who's gonna do this interview who's
going to get this who you going to
ascend so what you're saying is hard
work don't matter no more what you're
saying is you are the high chief and the
appointee to who's going to do these
interviews who's going to get these
exclusives you are the gatekeeper for
that I say nay for that I won't lay down
I won't take that all you're gonna make
me do is go harder mmm I'm going to make
sure I get these interviews I'm going to
make sure we make acts like I'm going to
make sure any show that is anywhere that
iron Lords will be then it's not
breathing down your neck all the trash
I'm going to be forced to open the doors
and allow us to get in to get the
interviews that we worked so hard for
pause and that's why I say this yo if
III it is gonna do what they want in the
long term but what they're gonna have to
realize 100% they have to stop toeing
the line yeah they have to make that
event an event that's appealing to
people like us and and just the gamers
wanting to go right the last two years
when they've had they've had gamers
coming in there they've had overpriced
passes they've had super long waits in
line all the things all the negative
stuff there thankfully log net kind of
been able to sidestep the last few years
because
what up and absolutely I think III
survives that way III has to become a
100% consumer centric event 100% because
that that gives it gives them the money
they want to make right and it also
gives people like us the opportunity to
continue to go and and and now remove
from all this digital stuff that we may
not have access to because I King said
Jeff could he don't know me by name you
don't know it's different so if he's the
steward of this moving forward it's me
we're not there yet we have so we have
to continue to be keep putting boots to
the ground and going to these events
interviewing people so how does that
happen
it happens by these events becoming 100%
consumer centric 100% mmm no I feel
adjusting I want to jump in real quick
cuz I I hate it I had a concerns I
everything going on um you know Sheldon
Sheldon law GE probably still do check
you know we've been talking behind this
behind the scenes and obviously the
landscape is evolving right things are
changing in front of our very eyes or
certain things however I have heard
positively for the guys for the content
Koreans for the for the provocateurs for
the the website owners and stuff like
that because of this adjustment actually
some velvet rope is being cut because
what has happened now with this whole
digital age ding some developers are
like look yes I'm gonna give all this
information to the you know the bigger
outlets or stuff like that but I'm also
going to give it to these guys and this
outlet is so it's actually still not
necessarily cutting the little guy out
so to speak from what I'm here again I
can only speak on myself I can only
speak on large gaming I always for what
I'm seeing I'm still seeing positive
strides that they are going to still
reach out to us and do that and not just
be limited because again they're not
beholden to a location to a space they
are still they listen companies at the
end of the day they want the information
out they want people to know about that
game what they're working on they want
this information out so the day I know
for us as the hard core sometimes we
like y'all this looks scary this looks
spooky I don't know I mean I'm saying
but again it's early for
what I'm hearing things are just
evolving and changing we got to see how
it's gonna play out but I do agree with
what phase point it did show me how
strong Keighley hand is oh yeah this
joint you don't say I've listened I'm I
respect Geoff Keighley for being a gamer
and his passion I've had my issues with
him in the past over two things we know
about the deafening thing you know how I
feel about that you know I'm saying as
far as the connection to closeness and I
kind of never forgave him with the Xbox
one ex I think I think he I still think
he was eat that and I'm wrong because
because people like him especially him
growing as fast as he was I don't think
he would have intentionally liked that
unless he was asked to again minor
things those are just my nitpicks
overall do I think he's good for gaming
yes is he trying to move things and get
things poppin I do I love the game
Awards as a showcase like our enemies
our Oscars or yes love all that let
gaming rock like I said we got to see
how this goal I'm not gonna catch the
evil thing on them yet until I got to
see how you move and I got to see how
the developers move in reverence to the
community that that's all I got on a
player we'll see man it's a big thing
man anything I haven't said anything yet
sort of I think as much as we I hate to
say this because you know we do I think
he threw is done they might have one
more year but um I think I think Geoff
was looking at in d3 you said that
Schreyer actually agrees with you he
denied it
some Ageha fest came up he was like this
is effectively the nail in the coffin I
don't think he three little I think if
they might survive a couple years maybe
one more maybe two but I think the
moment that these companies start saying
yo like first off I think people respect
Geoff more than the people who run the
e3 these days I think that the I think
jeff has got the support of the industry
right I mean the fact that that feel
Spencer felt comfortable enough to rule
to reveal their next column so in the
video game award speaks volumes yeah I
think it's just a matter of time maybe
maybe two years the e3 is done then
write me anything
didn't feel safe they kind of they like
faith like they was gonna fake rehearsal
so would get levy I mean even if they
know it's been boots no judge knew Jeff
was one of the only people that knew oh
oh I thought yeah well see no they did
that for everyone else in there because
no one else knew besides the people
running it and Jeff right right let me
get you super Chad we gotta go um yo
Cyrus Burke follow us I'm sure nutty dog
is working on two games right now so why
would the hacker only leak one game
after the infinite delay yeah we did
that we did that okay do we get restored
Hades yeah we got Hades the next week at
first we had a manual a-okay yeah man
you a lord King always gives us the good
word thanks brother yours I think that's
Talk That Talk King on God in them we
got a super sticker from NY team a table
we really appreciate the support you
should have put some words in there man
you don't have to just do the sticker I
feel you thank you thank you build that
coalition of youtubers mixture and
twitch streamers of content creators
band together the force that stand it
gets to Titan right of the elite shout
out to Gotham got him salute Gotham got
turned on a super chat love your show
guys King David you put the nail right
on the head as always brother so glad I
was able to meet you last year at Xbox
fans boomstick hope and III stays and
becomes more like fan fest son oh god
guys educate god bless man I hope it was
a good experience we might have been
live but that's a loot man look it's
it's real we'll see what happens man
let's get a body here man we got the
last one we got it we gotta roll man we
went we like crazy long okay yo did
y'all see that stadia connection and you
know no no it's okay
yo I love how they did it what I love
everything about it
it was all about the games they show
developer real quick listen
stadia is learning Google is learning oh
oh Google is listening to what's working
Google that stadia Kinect was legit
maybe the games weren't maybe the games
weren't right
maybe the games wasn't but could you
imagine
when the games are and they have that
format feels like it in a Nintendo
treehouse it was it was a Nintendo
Direct in their format they gave you the
games they give you the information and
boom boom bang bang bang when the games
is coming what's up there you can also
get stadia free right now they gave you
information they showed you games and
they got out of there they didn't get in
their own way that's what that pop G
cross-play I figured you might be one of
that I know I would
you're I'm not gonna front mm-hmm this
made me say y'all might give stadia try
now all right you know the drunken ninja
shout out to ILP on this beautiful day
shut out my girl a proud new Xbox 1x
owner 75 over 200 a they being
disrespectful low population gaming what
the hell is state yone going it Oh real
quick this last time we all go quick on
this what's your 50 I'll just catch it
stay do is the same beam interests you
is this into is this in the bushes
I'm already on look at the other day
it's nice to not play Oh some cheaters
on Steam plain destiny well I need them
games off like I need the stuff that you
know first off put X come on there put
something I could play this not
multiplayer never lets me row okay attic
will prove of stadium mm-hmm it's not
that bad even play multiplayer on you
know um destiny it's not that but but I
have to say that I did play it on my PC
like I can't talk from still like
playing on your tablet on the on the on
the cell phone providers network I can't
talk about stuff like that but it's not
a bad service no it's not and if they
get they stuff together I
could actually compete with the consoles
no doubt the original stadia tested you
totally [ __ ] you is rotted in the
beginning it did I was hated and I ride
a u-turn what's up cuz I listen cuz the
399 is just temporary
maybe woulda come out be like free night
you know what 399 for for life whatever
or just bring down that overall price or
yes yeah that whole you have to buy the
game wholesale like you would purchase
it in the store and you're getting an
actual either digital copy of it or or
physical copy of it eliminate that and
I'll be on board and then show me show
me something from your Studios that's
absolutely substantial like way break
like that the way I like the way
breaking I'm like legit he was doing bad
moves it's not it's not enough for for
that same pricing model and just you
know trying to and the thing is again I
don't I don't care to have to go in a
couple of months later and cancel my
subscription like now forget it I that
what I will say is yes the technology is
fantastic if stadia stadia will be
around in some way shape or form if it
doesn't say a stadia and they just kind
of license out the technology to other
people that's something that can happen
but again currently with the way they're
doing business I don't you don't like
how to charge of people but I'll make it
quicker I get out of it you don't look
I'd be I was like I wasn't really
interested at first when I was listening
to the joint you know I'm saying but um
you know look they extended it for
another two months
ador pub G was a good look I honestly
think that's the lane they need to go I
think what they need to do is realize
look make stadia pro your game pass add
stuff into that service and got the
destiny fans in there because cheese
cheaters are pcs running rampant you
can't do the ain't stuff you can't hack
not an animal stadium right so promote
that is your mo top player and they Loki
are on 2000 on Twitter but they got a do
more of it I need to see the division up
in there I need to see more duty war
zone up in there
I need this if you ever watch go over
what Google got the ball game yeah so
start adding them games in there make
you the multi player drink now again
like it's Ava's right though you gotta
have your own exclusives you gotta have
some choice in there you know I'm saying
but um look I mean I thought it was you
know I was surprised
octa path travelers coming over there no
surprise ei was in the bag you know I'm
saying all that they be man Messi why
these games didn't come to switch
between go get to that on the whole game
I'm like you all stayed here but that's
weird to me but um look it's another two
months
they're trying I thought the show agree
with King it was concise it was quick
boom-boom-boom in out but here's the
main thing where them features dog when
you first announced stadia you were
saying I was going to be able to play on
my favorite youtuber we be able to
integrate and we is going through all
this stuff and I've yet to see it you
can't even share a screenshot or stadium
like what's going on like wit features
some ways in some ways did Nintendo
switches better than Stadium which when
you're when the tittle switches out dude
you and features you need to go back to
the drawing because you clearly messed
up switch is out anybody oh okay we got
any the ladies in the room good oh look
at that you like what podcast is this
why are you running
why are you running
you're right the latest Xboxes eggs
reveal showcasing gays specifically for
from global development partners only do
you feel this is a mistake by Microsoft
to not show Xbox first party offerings
first the choices are a yes multiplex is
not the way to go show those Xbox
exclusives and be priority B no don't
show your entire hand yet
Sony has yet to announce anything but a
logo and controller or C I don't care I
did it this same energy for the Xbox
series X logo review please rocky our
people when it goes up on Twitter
Lord Fame entertainment 2k up in the
building absolute pleasure we held the
man hostage for three damn house and he
spelled rocked out and didn't complain
my bad brother it was just a good show
we kept talking to all of wicked five
people Fozzie what you got going on a
bit amen I am at fan GMT 2k
across-the-board YouTube Twitter also
follow the at level one gaming cuz on
511 we're gonna be a national you thinks
here and there but yeah man also every
Wednesday I do the double xp I guess I
got one hell of a team older babies
trying to grow and do they things to
make you guys check outside 7 p.m.
central on my channel and also another
channel which I can't quite announce yet
511 y'all please ban salute this brother
long overdue is finally we made this
happen
mokuba pomp this was necessary just
needed for growth and togetherness in
the wrong concern what you doing brother
we like to see your trajectory and what
you got cooking man so I look forward to
next time bro I already know you already
know always welcome here in the realm
Lord debuting the face cam put it off
like literally at like 3 o'clock I was
supposed to be at here
you know meet me and fade definitely
have a pass but oh yeah I got married
love for look go there follow this man
on Twitter ma'am yes second off that the
realms community is so supportive like
I'm speechless right now you guys
definitely came through man we already
almost have a 200 likes that that chats
been on crazy the super chat and
everything man we appreciate we came
here every week and it's like I said
everything you guys give those we
reinvest straight back into the podcast
you know that's the reason I'm here is
because this green screen I wouldn't
have my brother tell me how the great
squeeze up it should be don't don't mess
with that it feel I guys Zach but you
know I we want to thank everyone of you
for coming in here it was an amazing
show we will most we had 305 people at
one point is a little bit big and we're
coming from throat from the beginning
where we only had like 10 in there you
know we will nothing will humble you
more than growth and all of you guys
have been coming here every week
absolutely miss Luke today chat
absolutely all fire Lord saw but good to
have you back brother
feeling better man we could have found
people find a nosegay first off I just
want to say thank you to fame for coming
through ACOG said earlier who's clapping
for the Rona I wasn't clapping for the
Rowan I was clapping for the man and
made it weeks ago us on your timeline
you put something up that broke my heart
you said that you know you were feeling
worse and worse and and your daughter
would come to the door and sing to you
and I was just at that absolutely broke
my heart man so I'm so pleased and happy
to have you healthy and here with us man
I'm so happy the journey the fact that
you know whatever whatever it is that
that kind of made you say you know what
I got a I got a take I gotta live my
life even more so now right now and
everything that's in my mind that I feel
I can do I'm gonna try to do mmm Oh
preciate you having you here brother
shut up that's right god bless and like
addict said thank you to everybody for
coming through every
a week man you guys in here we seeing
new faces every week people having fun
with the book of X stuff like Smitty's
myth like these guys were all at us man
we try to do that yeah sure like so it's
absolutely amazing again oh I wanna
apologize as well I mean next week Lord
sovereign will be on screen the problem
is like I see green screens aren't you
supposed to project something I see I
don't want to put the bad just a bunch
of debuted now he'd make a de maiz he
would I don't want my mid-back I just
wanted to block off the bat for me last
night you I was up to like 4:00 in the
morning cuz I'm like alright I first of
all I need I need to shave oh my god
looking crazy rough and then last night
I'm like you know what am I gonna rep
tomorrow on green screen so I'm sorry
yes I'm trying to the the Streets of
Rage thing up right so it's like it's
weird cuz you gotta mess with it and
then you got a message the chroma and
like yeah so it didn't work working out
the kinks this weekend
let's get that demographic that dope gig
was go away five five years ago I've
been the need of my man thing work I've
been in media I didn't know the the
character of the man that I have met
before me today alright and I learned
the character of the man and the man is
he's a man because the first things that
he said was babysit now you look at
these affairs in order
this is the passwords to all
that in the third because as the head of
the household as the man in the house so
you take care of all that stuff so you
know so she don't have that headache and
that worry you understood what was going
on and you know I know you is praying to
whoever you believe in at the same time
you was a realist and then going through
your journey I can't even put myself in
your shoes to see the things that you've
seen and like you saying yeah these
people is gonna have some type they need
some type of counseling because he said
he's suffering from these PTSD type
nightmares from this situation to admit
that to be that open and honest sir I
took the hat to you sir Thank You Man
and thank you for sharing you know um so
when we do get a chance to get out
definitely give my behind over there to
Texas we definitely do I ride up on that
horse you'll have to teach me you know
King will be playing Red Dead the same
Kos is Oh make sure you check out that
uh that affordable line you know Hulk
I got something else that I might do a
for double line this week actually I got
a couple affordable lines coming through
because a big statues coming out I saw
some pre-orders that was coming up and
they actually ship and I saw some guys
get those remember my shooting 4k
everything done in 4k so if you have the
ability to watch in a 4k you can watch
the your car told me this week mm-hmm he
said my man what's up man you sweatin I
said I took the shower I dabbed the face
I said you know why she said be
glistening but um
I said I was just listening he said boy
that 4k crazy my dad bought every
yo crazy is it is freezing down here in
this basis I need a jacket on and then
hat is because it is freezing I make
sure that the heat and stuff is all
because that boiler make a lot of noise
yeah all right so I don't want to be you
know interrupting your guys fun so I
freeze down here sitting in this room
for four for three hours
I freed I make sure I got shoes on so my
toes don't get sacrificed for you so I
also appreciate every last person that
comes into this chat assisted that views
that we can pull you away from what's
going on at this point in time and a
level level of retainer ship from
beginning to the end you guys are
rocking with us and I'm rocking with you
it's fantastic thank you so much I am
truly humbled like addict says this is
amazing
you got four guys that just hang out and
shoot the crap yeah with each other and
you guys are rocking with us and that
that just you know warms my heart every
time super humbling man yeah I can't
kitty said it best again thanks more
favor coming through long overdue chat
was all file of the topics band was
great show got some more fun next week
should be extra stupid chat oh wow
mister catch the Oh perfect shotgun
which is a thumbs up man - lot of super
chat no one above and above that get
that from you I'm missing things we've
got a $5 super job from drunken ninja
I'm pretty sure I don't know yeah I'll
shout out to ILP on this beautiful day
and shout out to my girl I just wanted
to make sure okay everybody let's all I
got everybody enjoy your Sunday days for
rockin with us we gonna get you that
flock that's today over here
everybody judges so they get this little
outro we out of here man peace Oh
oh yeah it's pretty sniffs eh we got
permission Thank You y'all peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]